that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not your voice that's
not actually your voice that's not you
telling yourself that you suck that
voice was planted there that voice was
put there by somebody else in your life
and probably early on growing up telling
you that you can't do something you were
not born you didn't come out of the womb
and say I suck I can't do anything no
you're playing you're experimenting
you're finding Joy you're laughing
you're doing it and then along the way
people tell you that you can't do it
that you should stop that you should
quit that it's not gonna work out that
you can't do it and we've been so
conditioned around that that we take it
on and we think it's our voice when you
come up with an idea just Workshop this
you come up with an idea I'm gonna write
a book I'm gonna start a YouTube channel
I'm going to launch his business I'm
going to whatever you can with your your
bucket list your dream life your vision
board you come with a list of ideas
things that you think that you want to
do things that you feel confident that
you'd love to create for yourself right
what happens the next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends before
that happens we crap on our own ideas
right you look at that list the next day
and say I can't do that it's ourselves
telling ourselves that we suck but the
problem is we've taken on that voice and
we think that it's us that's not your
voice that is not your voice telling you
that you suck that is somebody else's
voice that has been conditioned to be
there that we're so used to being there
that we have taken on as our voice it
has become your identity but it was not
your voice it was put there knee
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael and we
make these videos probably because
you're the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you need that Push by surround
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best my husband
Evan Carmichael and our take on his top
10 rules for Success enjoy
it was a seed that was planted that has
been grown over time and you need to rip
that weed out
that is not your voice
you do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh that was my you
know the bully at school whoever that
person was now think about okay it's
that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore hopefully that creates
an aha moment for you that starts to
actually shift things because
we've been so conditioned to listen to
that voice that we don't recognize that
we actually have a choice to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice
so that's step one step two then is
whatever you want more of in your life
you need to be surrounded by it more you
need to change the environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you where you are
and if you're watching this video I love
you thank you for being here you are
probably the happiest most optimistic
most positive most caring most pouring
into other people that's in your
environment if you think about you and
your friends and your family you're
you're the most optimistic person in
your family you're the most positive
person in your family you're the most
ambitious person in your family you're
the one who wants to care and serve the
most in your family right but
you know you're capable of way way more
right you know you can do way more than
what you're doing right now
and so you end up being this big fish in
a really tiny pond where you're serving
others and point in others and you wish
they could do more and that's amazing
don't stop caring for others but you
need more of a push yourself you need to
be around the people who are doing
things that you want to do on a higher
level
so the environment really matters in
your environment right now is is good
it's it's not terrible maybe it is
terrible but it's not great
most likely it's just good
and it keeps you stuck and it keeps you
in slow growth mode and it prevents you
from becoming the person that you
actually want to be so how do you start
to shift that will you shift your
environment
and you may say well Evan I don't know
people who are super accomplished and
are living the life that I want to live
I don't have any of those friends if I
did I wouldn't be still stuck here and I
hear you I get it so the fastest way to
do it isn't through actually trying to
make those friends it's
through what I call aspirational mentors
it's by watching videos like this you
may never meet me you may never meet Mel
Robbins you may never meet whoever your
heroes are but you can learn from it
through these videos whoever you want
more of whoever you you respect and
maybe you're even jealous of that they
can think that way and live that way be
around them more
look at who you subscribe to on YouTube
look at who you subscribe to and follow
on Instagram look at the books you read
in the podcast you listen to and the
shows that you watch are they from the
people who make you feel better about
yourself and give you hope inspiration
and courage to go Live Your Dream and if
not then switch it out
switch it out
if you are watching YouTube when you
just found that you you wasted the last
three hours of your life
it's not YouTube's fault
it's your fault
you're subscribed and watching the wrong
videos
because there's a lot of positivity out
there if you close a YouTube session you
feel worse about yourself then you
subscribe to the wrong channels if
you're watching this video and feel
worse about yourself one I sincerely
apologize and two you should unfollow me
and go follow somebody that that makes
you feel more hopeful and Alive because
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel hopeful alive bold
confident powerful things are possible
your life will change
but we need that external stimulus you
are a product of your environment you
have to have those people around you you
can have Elon Musk and Mel Robbins and
Tony Robbins and whoever pushing you
every day you can have them pushing you
every day
by consuming their content we just
happen to be enslaved
by
the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all yeah YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive
so addictive you you get one video that
then takes you down another path and
another path and now all of a sudden
you've just watched three hours of
videos on something that doesn't make
your life better you don't actually
really care about you just got sucked
into the drama of a certain storyline
has that ever happened to you
referrals I watched the Michael Jordan
tribute the last dance and I went to
research
one of the story lines of Scottie Pippen
and Michael Jordan to see kind of what
the 2022 updated version was and all of
a sudden I got down this Rabbit Hole of
Scottie Pippen versus Michael Jordan and
three hours later there's still other
videos to watch like what am I doing
this is a waste of time I don't even
care that much about these guys
I watched the last dance it was a great
documentary and and I learned from it
and I love the drive and tenacity and
hustle but I don't care about the drama
between Michael Jordan and Scottie
Pippen and so we will easily default
back into that Comfort mode and back
into consuming drama
you have to with intention try to bring
that back
so here's a grid
homework assignment go look at your
YouTube homepage and see what's being
recommended to you and how many of those
videos whether it's my Channel or other
channels how many of those how many of
the videos on your home page right now
will make you a better human will make
you feel more proud of yourself will
make you feeling hopeful confident
courageous ready to take some action on
some of your goals and how many of them
are drama how many of them are pure
entertainment how many of them you know
will lead to some giant rabbit hole that
you don't want to go down if you
actually set out your calendar and say
how do I want to spend my day with
intention how many of these videos would
actually lead you towards that path
right and for too many people it's it's
not a it's not a pretty picture
we're listening to the wrong people
and so you can change that
you know you could change that if we
Circle back you recognize that the
negative voice in your head is not your
voice it was planted there by somebody
else who hates their life and you don't
want their life
then you switch it to say okay well
whose life do I want and ultimately you
want your best version of your life but
to get there you're taking different
pieces from different people's lives
like oh I like how he does that and she
does that and and she does this and
you're pulling different people
different things from different people
and then you start to surround yourself
with that
and the shift doesn't happen overnight
but if you're constantly pouring these
people into you if you're constantly
pouring Evan Carmichael into you you're
gonna start to believe more in yourself
and if you're constantly pouring other
people into you you're gonna start
thinking like them behaving like them
taking on their mindsets and their
beliefs
and if those are beliefs that you want
and the mindset that you want amazing
you get to choose now
you're in control
you've been a product of your
environment your early environment with
negativity your ongoing environment with
probably just mediocrity keeping you
where you are and now you can change it
you can shift it you can decide to be in
a different spot one year from today
and the most important step you can do
is to start choosing and carefully
decide with intention who you want to be
around
so that in one year from now you are in
a different spot not just for you but so
you can serve others and lift them up to
catch up as well rule number two do
meaningful work there is no work-life
balance there's just life
the fact that we are separating work
from life
I think is a big problem I think that's
why most people hate their life
because we don't see work as a part of
life your work is a part of life your
work should fuel your life your work
should give you purpose and meaning we
all want to wake up and feel like we
matter and we're going to do something
today in our work that's going to create
some kind of positive impact right on
the days when you wake up and you feel
like today is going to matter I'm gonna
make something that is going to matter
to another human being maybe a million
people maybe one person but today is
gonna matter those are the days that you
love your life and you feel amazing and
you feel like you're contributing and
you feel like this is yes this is why I
do what I do
and on the days when you feel like it
doesn't matter nobody cares if you show
up you're not making anything meaningful
there is no contribution those are the
days where you hate your life
there is no work-life balance guys it's
just life
when I'm on podcasts and people ask me
this question like what does work-life
balance mean to you or they ask me some
variation of it like how many hours a
day do you work or what is your work
calendar look like it's like well what
what's work to you is my usual response
now I'm sitting here on your show I'm
having a great time we're doing this
podcast together
is this work for you
like does this count as work because I
don't see this as work
this isn't work this is fun
this is fun for me this is my life I
like this when I see this podcast in my
calendar I'm excited by it I don't look
at it as work
making these videos I don't see it as
work that's why I've been able to stay
so consistent
right how do I not burn out it's another
question to get us a lot how do you not
burn out how do you make so many videos
how do you not burn out
a lot of people burn out
nowhere even close to the number of
videos that that I've done over
how many years 13 years
a lot of years guys it's been a lot of
years of showing up and making
over 10 000 videos crazy how why well
because it doesn't feel like work this
this is part of my life
it's a it's this is what a purposeful
life looks like if I saw it as work I
would have quit and given up
years ago I mean a decade plus ago
there are some pieces of
what I do that feels like work you know
doing accounting stuff feels like work I
hate that stuff doing administrative
stuff paperwork legal stuff that feels
like work I burn out very quickly I
don't want to spend I want to spend the
least amount of time as possible on that
I want to hire people have a great
lawyer have a great accountant have a
great bookkeeper have people help me
with that stuff because I do not enjoy
it it feels like work and if my calendar
was just filled with that stuff I would
hate my life
so I I don't I don't believe in
work-life Balance I I reject the the
premise
of the entire question
it's just life
how do you want to spend your life and
this is one of the greatest things that
we have as entrepreneurs you get to
decide what your life is you get to pick
the business you go into you don't have
a boss besides the customers but you
still also get to pick which customers
that you work with
and your your work
should be something that is a source of
joy for you and a source of energy for
you because when you love what you're
doing every day it will bring you a lot
more happiness and satisfaction in your
life
so it's all just life
one of the great things I think that you
can do
is look at your calendar see what's
coming up in the next couple weeks a
couple months and are you excited to buy
the things that are in your calendar
and I I put everything in my calendar I
love living by my calendar
um
I don't know if it's because I don't
remember what I'm doing you know
tomorrow or I'm so present focused that
I don't know what's I don't know what
I'm supposed to be doing tomorrow so I
have it in my calendar and it I think it
also reduces anxiety for me to know that
I've got days for things so making
videos I don't worry during the week
about making videos because I know on
Tuesday it's my video day and I'll get
it all done and if I get an idea for
video I'll email myself and I'll look at
that on Tuesday so it's in my calendar
so I have I have a spot for everything
so I'm not constantly worried before I
had a calendar I'd be worried and
anxious about oh when am I going to get
this done when do I have time to do this
and that would stress me out we're now
like okay I know I'm I'm gonna do that
on Tuesday when am I gonna have time to
Mentor my team okay I'm gonna have to
all right Monday we're gonna time to
have you know
um clean up the condo and and do grocery
shopping whatever okay that's Sunday
right so it's all in the calendar so
at least for me having a calendar has
been life-changing
but what ends up happening is we we
don't put everything in our calendar we
just put our meetings in our calendar
where I put everything I put I put time
with Nina my calendar time with my son
and my calendar uh time
playing League of Legends and Minecraft
is in my calendar you know stuff is it's
in my calendar so I have I have time to
get everything I want out of life done
you have time
this this reason I've I don't have time
like if if I was to step into your life
and see what you were doing every day
there's a lot of wasted time
it's a lot of unintentional time
so the whole idea of having a calendar
is to be more intentional be more
intentional with how you're spending
your time
and if you do that then
you can look at your week ahead your
month ahead and are you excited this is
all life right forget where life balance
is all live so you look at your life
what's in your calendar are you excited
by the things that are in there
are you excited by the projects you're
working on are you excited by the people
you're going to be connecting with are
you excited by the amount of time you're
spending just to yourself whether that's
meditation or yoga or working out or
swimming or walking or whatever are you
spending enough time just for you
are you excited about the life that is
in your calendar and if not then change
it what are we doing here this is why
you became an entrepreneur
if you want to live somebody else's
version of your life go get a job where
you're told what to do you're told when
to show up you're told what you have to
work on that's that's a job that's why
most people hate their lives because
they're being told what to do constantly
all the time they have no freedom
if you want to be an entrepreneur and
have ultimate freedom
then let's take control of our calendar
because we're not
most entrepreneurs that I meet are feel
out of control
are wasting a ton of time feel that
they're not spending their time being
intentional you know they're capable of
so much more know they can be a lot more
efficient a lot more productive a lot
more purposeful
with how they're spending their time
so if there's nothing in your calendar
that's exciting you
then you you do not like your life
because your calendar is reflection of
how you're spending your life
so change it now maybe that's a drastic
change
or maybe that's a minor change
and this is an ongoing evolution
whenever I feel
unhappy uh not like depressed because
that doesn't really happen but when I'm
feeling
when I'm feeling that the energy is off
probably a better way to put it whenever
I feel like the energy is off for one
day not the end of the world right for
one day
just go do the thing that's in your
calendar because you said you were gonna
do it right but if this happening for a
couple days in a row or if it's
happening for Tuesdays is my filming day
for example if I had two or three
Tuesdays in a row where I feel the
energy is really off
and I'm not enjoying making videos
then I need to Pivot and it's either I
need to
make different kinds of videos
or I need you to stop making videos
that may happen I'm willing to drop
things if it doesn't bring me joy
anymore
and we as humans stay in things for far
too long like there are things that
you're holding on to that you should
have dropped maybe years ago and you're
still doing it why because it's a habit
a routine or or it's sunk cost like you
had this goal five years ago that
doesn't even matter to you anymore but
you've built your self-identity around
it be willing to let go of things sooner
because you'll never win doing work that
you hate
and so there may come a day where
I just dropped my YouTube channel all of
them because it doesn't fill me with joy
anymore now I don't think that's gonna
happen anytime soon because I still love
doing this stuff
rule number three praise your effort not
the result everything in your life
changes when you learn to tie your
self-worth to your effort instead of the
results most people tie their software
to the results to winning you only feel
good about yourself when you win if
that's how you think then you're screwed
because that person only takes on
projects that you know you have a pretty
high chance of winning at and therefore
you play small for Life the key is to
tie yourself Worth to the effort to
trying and if you do that well you'll
win Beyond Your Wildest imaginations so
let's use me as an example look at this
video right here this video
two minutes before getting on and making
this video
I'm nervous
I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done 6 000 of these videos
do I not love it anymore nope that's not
it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through I put this
pressure on myself to say this video
right now has to be the best video that
I've ever made that's my intention going
in to every time I'm filming most days I
don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and Bolder most of the
time you won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and the nose accumulate and then you get
another one and another one and another
one and so the answer isn't have a big
goal and then find a reason why you
can't do it the answer isn't dream big
and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
ability to get up and try again and try
again and try again and pat yourself on
the back for the effort you're putting
in not just when you're winning so how
do you do it I'm gonna give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is what I call the
pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah
heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing this
is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably going to go down
that's part of the experimentation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance it works
amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make a video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it it
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos come back go back to my
main Channel go back to the beginning
see where I started I've kept them all
up so you can see the journey the
progress of how much I sucked at the
very beginning it took me 350 videos
until I wasn't embarrassed by my content
I was I was so embarrassed I couldn't
watch it back 350 videos but I kept
going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and said what would the
most bold version of you do it just came
out man I love that
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what was
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities to force yourself
to be bold and you want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous but we don't live in that
land very often and so if you ask that
question what would the most bold
version of you do today
what it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
rule number four keep practicing
practice gives you ultimate freedom the
more you practice the better you get at
something the more skilled you are at it
the more information you have the more
it actually allows you to play more have
more fun be more flexible and have
ultimately more freedom this is
something I struggled with a lot in the
early days of my speaking career I was
asked to speak at a bunch of events and
this is what 20 years ago I guess I've
I've had as a speaking career now and I
used to be so worried about
disappointing people that I would
memorize my entire speech I would
practice and practice and practice and
practice and practice and just memorize
my speech to the point where
word for word it would be the exact same
thing every time and I thought that was
good I thought that's what you're
supposed to do obviously yes practice
makes perfect keep going keep practicing
keep doing it and what ended up
happening was yes I delivered the same
speech each time but I think the worst
thing you can do as a speaker is just
give the exact same speech every time
we did a session of Movie Makers around
the signature talk it was one of the
most voted topics was how do I give my
signature talk and I think having one
signature talk is actually not great I
think you should be able to
be able to speak to the audience every
time your job if you're a speaker is to
give your audience a fantastic
experience and so it's knowing who's in
the audience don't assume it's the same
people every single time
right so you have to be able to know so
much about your subject that then you
can have your framework that you operate
in but then give a lot more value to
People by making a custom to them
so now whenever I'm doing a speaking gig
I'm always asking okay tell me about the
audience tell me who's here tell me why
people are setting it up what are people
here for both in terms of the
information they're hoping to get as
well as their background and their
interests and their concerns and what
they struggle with and of course there's
genuine human struggles that everybody
goes through but why are people here at
this conference and so here's my process
right now when I'm doing a a speech or
talk
they're gonna have me coming they're
going to talk about believer
entrepreneurship or YouTube it's gonna
be some set themes you're not having me
come to talk about my apple strudel
recipe
one right I'm coming in and talking
about things that are inside my domain
perfect
and I could easily just get up on stage
and talk
but I want to know who's in the audience
so before going I'll ask them tell me
about the people who are going to be
here and then I'll frame my speech
around a couple of key ideas that I
think would be valuable to that audience
still sitting within kind of the my
usual domain perfect
I'll practice it I'll practice giving a
speech I'll practice the points at home
I'll practice I'll practice talking to
my dog I'll practice on the airplane on
the way over I'll practice to kind of
get a sense of the stories that I want
to tell that I think will be the right
fit
but then the day before and the day of I
like to be there a little early to to
talk to people to one makes me feel a
little more comfortable
um
be able to connect to people in the
audience so it's not just
people I don't know but I've had a few
conversations with people but two
in feeling the vibe out of the event
I'll often end up switching up part of
my talk again to make it as customizable
as possible to the people I'm talking to
and this isn't just a speaking thing
guys this is any interaction you're
doing you're trying to sell your product
trying to sell your service you're on a
call with somebody who could use your
product or service hire you as a coach
Etc you have to customize your pitch
customize your talk for them not just
give the same thing every single time
you're talking to somebody you have to
know what makes them tick know why
they're talking to you what their their
deep desires and fears are and address
those things so that you can close the
sale right it's the same thing I'm just
giving an example through speaking
has been willing to deviate
from your talk
to actually give more value
and I think again the worst thing you
can do as a speaker is just give get
unsafe you can get the same talk every
single time
that's what I used to think was the way
to go but this is actually a lot more
valuable
because you can inspire people but one
it becomes boring for you to get up and
just do the same thing over and over and
over again and two if you can customize
it to actually address the thing that
they're specifically concerned about
you're gonna have a bigger impact why
are you there you're there to touch
people you're there to move people to a
positive direction right
again whether whether you're speaking or
you're just talking to somebody on the
phone a potential client why are you
working with them yes they're going to
pay you but why you want them to get a
result you want them to move you want
them to make a change you want to solve
a problem for them and so the more you
can actually connect to what they're
struggling with the easier it is for you
to
to close the sale and have the impact
that you're trying to have so it's a lot
more fun it's a lot more impactful a lot
more meaningful and so that's my usual
process now why are people here
I'll prepare a version of my speech to
address those people and then it always
changes up the day of because I met
somebody in the lobby who inspired me or
I met somebody on the airplane the day
before who shifted my thinking a little
bit and gives me an extra story to tell
and when you're so prepared and you know
your stuff so much it's easy to add
those things in
when you don't really know
you're kind of all over the place
so it's being overly prepared and then
the day of being willing to be flexible
it's that like rigidity of practice and
practice and practice and knowing what
you're doing so much that allows you to
play when you show up it's the you know
going to sports you practice your free
throws so much your practice your
penalty shot so much you practice you
practice so much that allows you to be a
lot more flexible than play when it
comes to game time let me share another
quick example from the opposite side
where I was interviewing somebody so
instead of being the person on stage
speaking I'm interviewing somebody and I
recently had Tony Robbins on the channel
it was the third time it came on the
channel the first two interviews we did
had three million views on them combined
which is amazing and he's coming back
for the third time talk about his new
book and I'm always nervous before a big
interview
and this is probably the least nervous
I've been because it's the third time on
but I was still nervous going in and so
I'm preparing I'm preparing and
preparing and preparing I'm trying to
find a thread that I care about I don't
want to just ask the same questions
everybody else has asked I don't want to
just use the questions that is PR agency
sent over because he's going to answer
those questions on every other show I
want it to be different and unique and
fun and special and so I prepared I know
I've got
uh half an hour with him uh I know he
likes to go long in his stories you
don't get that many questions in so I
need to I need to really be careful of
what I'm gonna say and make this time
count
it'd be easy just to show up and ask
okay why did you write this book what
does it mean to you what do you hope
people get from it what was your
favorite part about it and then then
half an hour is done and you haven't
really asked anything super meaningful
so I'm preparing
and I wrote down on a notepad file that
I had opened when I was talking to him
you know four questions five questions
that I wanted to ask and I practice how
I would ask them I practice you know
what what I was going to say
and then I practiced it so much that
come game time come show time here we go
Tony's coming on let's let's do our
one-on-one
I was able to actually be present and
listen to what it was saying and and
play ball with him right to to throw and
catch with him instead of just going to
the questions when you haven't prepared
and you're really insecure you just go
to the questions you just go okay here's
what I said okay here and just ask the
question we're the best interviews are
when you can throw and catch right where
they say something and you take that a
little bit deeper as opposed to just
moving on to the next question because
I've watched a lot of interviews and in
the work that I do and one of the things
that I find most frustrating is
the person says something amazing and
you want them to it's like okay ask a
follow-up question and instead of asking
a follow-up question then just go to the
next question
because the interviewer it was never
even listening to what the interviewee
was saying they're just so worried about
getting the next question in that that's
that's all they're thinking about and so
like okay great and then tell me about
this next question without going deeper
into the conversation so I didn't want
to be that kind of interviewer even I
get it because you're nervous
you're not fully prepared you're worried
about the questions
so one example with Tony he was talking
about a recent Health scare that he had
and that his career would be over
the doctor said your career is over
and in my head I was thinking about some
of the other stuff I knew about Tony
Robbins and so I asked him how many
times have you been told that your
career is over
it was off script right it wasn't
something his team prepared it wasn't
something Tony's maybe been asked I
asked how many times have you been told
that your career has been over because I
remember uh you know he had this
tumor that made him grow crazy quickly
and and people said his life would be
over I remember he burned out his voice
box and his doctors told him he'd never
speak on stage again and now this injury
that happened to him he wasn't gonna be
able to go into his event so he's been
told consistently that his career would
be over
and yet he still gets up and he finds a
way and he does it right one of the
things that we love about his ability to
follow through and stay consistent and
so in the over preparation and knowing
his story and also knowing that I had
questions to fall back on in case
there was a lull on the conversation it
allows the play it allows the freedom it
allows you to adjust the situation which
then creates a much better experience so
whether you're speaking whether you're
interviewing whether you're coaching
whether you're mentoring whether you're
on a sales call
you need to know your script you need to
know what you're going to say you need
to understand your customer and who
you're talking to you need to know all
that and over prepare
but then understand that the greatest
asset that you have is not in rehearsing
again the script is that you have the
ability to be free now
that you can play because you've done
all the drills and now you need to have
the back and forth it's it's throwing
and catching I'm gonna throw the ball to
you you're gonna catch it you're gonna
throw the ball back to me it's not just
throwing where a lot of times the
biggest mistake is that you're just
throwing you're just throwing another
one and another one and here's my other
line here's my next question here's my
next pitch throw throw throw throw and
the person I'd be saying but there's no
receiving and them throwing the ball
back to you that's the best part in any
interaction if you have a goal to get
them to move forward to make a change in
their life just to sign you up to hire
you to work with you so you can make
that impact that you're trying to make
there has to be that back and forth and
the more prepared you are the easier it
is to then have the freedom to play also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five believe that you
are amazing what you believe about
yourself is the only thing that matters
at the end of the day no matter how much
outside affirmations you get or other
people telling you that you're amazing
if you don't believe in your heart that
you are amazing it won't none of that
will last like you've ever gone to an
event or you ever made a video or
created something or you're hanging out
with a friend and they tell you how
amazing you are and that feels good
right like the the external affirmations
and validation feels great but then it
fades that stuff doesn't last you don't
have somebody being a cheerleader for
you every day showing up in your bedroom
saying hooray go do this you're amazing
right we don't have that you have to be
that for yourself
if you're constantly only getting your
value as a human being from other people
when they tell you that you're amazing
you're never gonna love your life you're
never gonna love yourself
it has to come from you has to come from
you telling yourself and you believe in
that you are amazing
well okay so that's that's a lot of
words how do you actually go off and do
it
I think for me it's this is why I
believe that lack of belief is the
world's number one problem
you know I can go and meet somebody and
fill them full of belief for a moment
but if they still don't believe in
themselves and they're going home back
to a life that they they had before
because they don't believe in themselves
enough
and so you have to design habits and
routines in systems and schedules to
slowly shift your belief in yourself
forward
every single day
and a good chunk of that is what you say
about yourself
when you look at yourself in the mirror
what do you say when you think about
yourself what do you say a lot of a lot
of the stuff that we say about ourselves
we wouldn't we wouldn't say to our worst
enemies it's rough
I actually think it's great to be your
own worst critic
I think it's great I think honestly I
think for a lot of people we're not hard
enough on ourselves let me let me stick
with me for a minute we're not hard
enough on ourselves because in order to
get to where you want to go you actually
need to push yourself more the problem
is why we can't do it is
we don't love ourselves enough we're not
our biggest cheerleader enough you have
to balance those two things we're very
hard on ourselves but because there's no
self-love we're not cheering ourselves
on enough we're not our biggest
cheerleader
you can't handle it most people are
already at the breaking point you know
like sitting here in a parking lot these
you know those I guess it's kind of
blurry you can't really see them but
people hate their lives
they're barely hanging on most people
are barely hanging on
we're barely hanging on to what we're
doing we we can post all these great
things on Instagram or wherever and make
it look like we're enjoying our life but
most people are barely hanging on the
people who are judging you for your life
and telling you that you suck hate their
own lives they are barely hanging on so
how do we get through it well yes we can
be harder on ourselves but we need to
balance that with more self-love
you have to remind yourself of why
you're great what you're proud of what
you're grateful for
and it has to be consistent otherwise
you'll never get to where you want to go
and when you love yourself more that
actually allows you to be harder on
yourself
when you love yourself when you actually
feel it you can push yourself harder
you can you can be more
um
demanding of yourself
because it's not going to push you over
the edge because you're not tying your
self-worth
to you accomplishing that thing and when
you don't accomplish it you feel like a
loser
it's starting from a place of I'm
amazing
that allows you to be way harder on
yourself when I go to events
a YouTube event for example if I'm
talking about anything entrepreneurship
or YouTube related
um I'm going in thinking
I'm Kick-Ass
and because I feel that I don't need to
say that
like a lot of times we feel like we need
to say that because it's it's masking
and insecurity right it's like those
people who uh have you ever seen those
memes where
when people make a little bit of money
they've got all these chains and
everything but then the people who are
Ultra rich
who have all the money
you look even Jay-Z like early Jay-Z you
know he's got all this change and
everything and I was like doesn't care
you know just walking on a T-shirt and
some jeans
because he doesn't need to front
because he's just so self-confident now
that it doesn't matter now it's actually
expression instead of masculine
insecurity most of us are just masking
insecurities instead of actually being
self-confident and so when I'm going to
an event if I'm talking about YouTube
I'm walking in feeling amazing
and I don't need to
I don't need to walk around and say hey
look at me
and it's actually the opposite I can go
up and say hey where do I suck it's my
favorite question to ask why do I suck
where do I suck can you point it out if
I can find one person to tell me where I
suck at something how my videos suck my
thumbnails suck do I don't believe that
they suck
right
I think they're amazing
but because I think they're so amazing
it allows me to go a lot harder on
myself
and so people will give their honest
opinion and say hey here's how I think
it could be better
and so I think we need to do that more
in our lives we need to cheer ourselves
up more we need to cheer ourselves on
more so how do we do it let me let me
share some practical tips for you to
execute
number one
music in the morning
every morning one of the most important
things that I do is I put music on and
it's music that makes me move makes me
dance makes me there's some songs that
if it came on you would have to you
would have to move right doesn't mean
that you're up and like dancing through
the whole house going crazy in your
underwear first thing in the morning but
something that even if it's just making
your head Bob
there are songs if they came on would
make your head Bob and you'd probably be
singing maybe not out loud but singing
under your breath I'm gonna tune along
and be intentional with the lyrics
because if we're singing Out lyrics that
are negative
that has a lasting impact but if you're
singing Out lyrics that are positive
that also has a lasting impact
so be intentional with music that you
put on Every Day first start your day
with music it's a fastest way to change
your state to go from feeling low and
tired and just what what day is it what
am I doing I wake up every day like what
day is it what am I doing today yes but
I demand excellence and that that starts
with music because I don't have I don't
want to spend a lot of time trying to
get into the right state of mind I can
command it whenever I want just by
putting on the right song so be
intention with your music and the lyrics
being positive two
connect to the work that you're doing
and how meaningful it is
so the next thing I'll do is I'll take
the dogs out and then I'll go for what I
call a believe walk and it's probably
the most important part of my morning
routine is I go for a believe walk and
it's a minimum of 20 minutes and it's a
maximum of an hour
and I'll go for a walk by myself with 20
pounds on my back I'll go rocking uh
I'll walk to Tim Hortons usually get a
coffee
you know this costs two bucks two
something so I only had you know what's
the what's the best money I spend every
year well it's the 700 bucks
of going on my believe walk and getting
the coffee every morning and I'm
thinking about what's my intention for
the day and I'm thinking about what I
want to accomplish today and the lives
that I want to serve and the people I
want to help and and what I'm about to
do today
and
it's a mini celebration
where most of the time we wake up like
an accident right you wake up you're
probably late for something you
immediately look at your phone what's on
your phone it's other people's demands
for your time other people's emergencies
of what they think you should do with
your schedule today right that's what's
in your phone all the DMS and the emails
and the texts and the missed calls and
all it's all other people's agenda for
your time that that is not an
intentional life we wake up like an
accident and start falling into what
other people want us to do today that's
not what you need to do and you need to
protect your time
so the morning
having to believe walk for me if you
want to go on your own whether it's 20
minutes or an hour that's really just a
feel thing too I don't book anything
until 10 30 at the earliest in my
calendar most of my meetings would be 11
first meeting would be 11 movement
makers and brand lytics I'll start at 10
30. uh and before that there's nothing
officially planned or scheduled so that
it gives my morning free to do whatever
I want to do and so if I want to go for
a hour-long believe walk instead of 20
minutes I can do that because I'm
thinking because I'm brainstorming
because I'm I'm
going through an idea I treat that as
walking meditation
if you like to meditate meditate I mean
it's the same thing I just find
meditation doesn't really help me that
much I like something a little more
active so I go I believe walks
do those two things
put on a playlist put on music every
morning
with lyrics that inspire you
and then go for a believe walk
20 minutes
to think about what you want to do today
what you want to accomplish how you want
to spend your time where you want to be
intentional
so you can start living the life that
you want to live
because the only thing that matters how
you feel about yourself
are you proud of you today
are you happy with what you've done
today
are you
joyful in how you showed up for you
today and yes we ultimately want to
serve and help others
but the only thing that matters
is how you feel about yourself
so we can stop relying on external
validation in somebody else's words of
affirmation for us to
feel Worthy
and flip it to say I am worthy I am
amazing
I can do great things
and when you can shift into that energy
you will do great things rule number six
overcome the fear of failure the biggest
fear we have isn't failure you're not
afraid of failing the biggest fear we
have is of failing in front of other
people you're afraid of people's
judgments the reason why we stay stuck
the reason why you still are where you
are is because you're afraid of other
people's opinions you have
great ideas inside you you have great
ideas if you're watching this video
You're subscribed to this channel you
have great ideas you know you're capable
of more you know you want to serve you
know you want to help
and great ideas are flowing through you
and we shut them off
you shut them off because we find a
logical reason why we can't do it right
the logical reasons in our head are well
the timing's not right or I don't have
the gear right on the connections or uh
you know I'm in the wrong country or
whatever logical excuse that we come up
with that's that's listen it's based in
reality it's actually based in fact
because you wouldn't you're a smart
person you wouldn't believe a stupid
reason
so the reasons that we're listening to
are actually based on some kind of fact
but they're still an excuse and
underneath it underneath that reason why
you can't do something is because you're
afraid
you're afraid I'm afraid we're afraid of
taking the next step and the fear
underlined that is not the fear of it
not working out it's the fear of it not
working out and who's going to see you
fail
we're so tied up into what other people
think about us that we'd rather play
small for life than actually go off and
accomplish and risk failing in front of
other people we're so afraid of that
that we never go off in
chase our dreams down and you're stuck
in this mental exercise of what you
could do
and then never actually doing anything
my biggest fear of disappointing people
you know it's that's still fear of
judgment it's still fear of I'm gonna
show up and speak in an event and it's
just not going to go well that that
people will
be unhappy with my speech and I put
a crazy amount of pressure on myself and
in my head I think people are here and
if I struggle then the whole thing is
ruined right I remember I was speaking
at printable shards event and uh it was
in Puerto Rico and people are paying
tons of money to be here
you know it was a 30 to 50 000
Mastermind and everybody's got giant
businesses right these are multi-million
dollar businesses owners who are in the
house and it was a multiple Day event I
think it was a three-day event and I'm
I'm speaking for one of them not even a
whole day I'm speaking I have one I've
got an hour or something of time right
at that event
in my head it's if I suck on stage then
people will freak out and be unhappy and
say this was a total waste of event
we're really I'm a really tiny nothing
part of this event right I mean people
are there to see Brendan burchard the
scene Dean graziosi to see the other
speakers there if any one speaker sucks
I mean if Brendan sucks that's a big
deal because he's speaking for 80 of the
time if I suck for one hour nobody's
really gonna care nobody's really gonna
be asking for a refund but
even though that's the the actual answer
it's not the it's not the thing that's
in my head and that's what we need to
fight that's what we need to fight
because I used to say no to
Opportunities because I was really deep
down just afraid that I would not be
able to deliver
I remember that I used to secretly hope
people would cancel on me
I would I would secretly hope that
interviews with cancer on me the
meetings would cancel on me
um
I remember I would book something out
like it's two months in advance right I
don't know if this has ever happened to
you this if this makes sense or if it's
happening to you let me know in the
comments
I would book something out that was a
month in advance for two months in
advance and so yeah I'm like that's
exciting I'd happy to do that and then
on the day of I look at my calendar and
say oh that's coming up and I would
secretly hope I would check my email I
remember I'd be checking my email hoping
that that person would cancel on me to
say oh I'm busy or I got sick or it's
not going to work out anymore and let's
reschedule and I remember I check in the
morning and I check two hours of four
and check an hour before and check half
an hour before and check 10 minutes
before and like if there was no email
then then I would go ahead and do it
so I'm losing insane amounts of
productivity right like how many times
am I checking my email before this thing
happens lose an insane productivity and
also not actually serving right not
actually living my mission my message
not not actually being proud of myself
for what I'm doing and it
it almost always worked out like I never
had an interview or a meeting or
something where I just massively
underperformed and actually sucked right
that that never really happened but I
was always afraid of it happening
and so I had to teach myself
this is what I want to do like the only
thing worse than me not doing this
is is me doing this and canceling right
or them me never doing an interview and
me never doing a meeting
and just recognizing that it was just
fear talking and again the fears of me
disappointing people and failing in
front of somebody else I'm sitting here
filming in in the car Nina just came
back we love you Nina
Nina's uh doing some grocery shopping
and I'm I'm filming here you know in the
car we got the dogs here in the back
seat timo's chilling and this used to
make me afraid you know that look
there's a guy who just pulled up next to
me
she's not watching but in my head you'd
be like this guy's watching
you have to be afraid of filming in a
parking lot be afraid of filming uh
walking down the street I'd be afraid of
filming with my sister in the room you
know I used to be afraid of all of that
so what is that
it's just fear of other people's
opinions why am I afraid of this guy
why I'm afraid of that guy I don't know
that guy
right
why am I afraid of him
first off he doesn't even care right
he's not even looking at me he doesn't
even care maybe he never even noticed
that I was filming period right so we
think people care they don't care
on the off chance that he actually cares
uh maybe he is judging me and thinks I'm
crazy holding this camera up with with
the tripod in my hand maybe he thinks
I'm crazy great uh if somebody's leading
with that then then they hate their own
life like if somebody's leaving with
just negative judgment he's got his own
issues to deal with that have nothing to
do with me or maybe he's inspired maybe
maybe this guy goes look he pulled out
his phone maybe he's making his own
YouTube video maybe he's inspired maybe
that guy is now going to be the next
YouTube sensation let's go
so we assume that everybody's gonna
watch us everybody's only looking at us
and
and we're gonna disappoint and be a
giant failure and everybody's gonna
laugh for me to kill us right like
that's the thought that's that's in our
head where the reality is most people
don't care
[Music]
most people right like 90 of people
don't even care
five percent of people might judge you
and they were in a really negative spot
themselves and the other five percent
maybe they're inspired by you and they
see that and they go and do something
with their life
but you playing small and listen to that
fear instead of actually taking some
kind of action will always lead to a
negative spot like you know that you
could do more you want to do more you
want to serve on a bigger scale but
listening to that fear
instead is keeping you stuck this is one
of the biggest problems for
entrepreneurs is that you you have all
these great ideas that are flowing
through you right you've got you've got
an endless list of ideas how big is your
list of things that you could do that
you get excited by when you look at them
and then how many are you actually doing
well not very many you're missing the
momentum because at the end of the day
you can write down a list of all these
reasons why it can't work out and and
when the timing is going to be just
right and perfect right I'll start this
on January 1st so I start this next
month or next week or Monday or on my
birthday or some artificial day you come
up with some reason of when you should
be starting this thing right but if you
actually examined it if you actually
took a little step back and looked at
your goals that you haven't hit that you
haven't started that just remain an idea
and you've never taken momentum on if
you actually took five minutes to step
back from it create a little distance
look at them
and look at your list of reasons why you
haven't started really it's just fear
and when you can catch that
that's when you make a life-changing
decision
because as long as you are not chasing
down the things that you want to do
because you're afraid of somebody else's
Judgment of you as long as that is a
thing that rules you you will never win
you'll never accomplish anything great
and you'll you'll live life with regret
so even now my my biggest fear is still
disappointing people
and the ongoing challenge is to catch it
and when you can catch it and when you
can know BS
catch it to say I'm just throwing up a
bunch of excuses but really I'm just
afraid when you can catch it
then
summon the courage to go do the
difficult thing summon the courage to
say I'm gonna I'm gonna take this fear
head on
because as long as that fear runs your
life
you stay stuck and every time you catch
the fear and you do it because of not
just feel the fear and do it anyway Feel
the fear and do it because of
you start to teach yourself to be a
little stronger a little more courageous
and you move a little bit closer to
becoming the person that you are capable
of being rule number seven follow
through most people don't get what they
want because you don't follow through
enough
just don't follow through it's based out
of insecurity you start and stop start
and stop you're afraid of hurting
people's feelings you're afraid of what
they're gonna say about you you're
afraid they're gonna judge you and
we're afraid of having that L on our
personal resume and so we we stop we
stop and try to do something else where
we're seeing more immediate results but
if it's your goal if it's your dream you
have to follow through one of my
favorite stories with Brendan Bouchard
and I went to speak at his event in
Phoenix and I I knew of him but I didn't
know him at the time it was his business
partner that had me come out to his
event
and hired me to speak there and that's
where I met Brendan for the first time
and he asked me hey what are you working
on what can I help or you know what's
next for you and I said I won't work on
my book and he said I'd love to uh I'd
love to help I'd love to give you some
feedback on your book like I am
definitely down for that
let's connect and uh he's he asked me
what my phone number was and at the time
I didn't have a phone I didn't use a
phone uh number and I said how about
email and he said oh I'm not really good
on email but if that's the only way then
let's do email so we exchanged emails
and uh I didn't I didn't hear from him
so I I followed up and I said hey
Brendan thank you you know great event
um love to talk about
the book like you suggested and didn't
hear back and followed up a couple weeks
later and didn't hear back and followed
up a couple weeks later and then he said
oh man thank you uh I'm super swamped
right now but uh let's see they're due
come out to my place and we'll do a jam
session or I've got this event coming up
maybe you can come be there I said yeah
I'm down for either which one you want
to do and didn't hear back and then
wrote a couple more messages and didn't
hear back and here's what's really
important
in my head every time I sent another
email I I was questioning myself I was
judging myself like oh I don't want to
bother him
um maybe maybe I'm I'm being too
overwhelming maybe maybe he doesn't
actually want me to come out uh maybe
I'm offending him maybe you know I'm not
respecting him maybe I'm asking for too
much you know that's that's the thought
in my head before every email where in
reality
he's he's just a busy guy he had a lot
of stuff going on he had a launch that
was happening that I wasn't even aware
of uh that he was planning behind the
scenes and so he is he was you know not
crazy stressed out but he just has a lot
on his plate that he's dealing with and
it's hard to tell ourselves that it's
easier to default to the insecurity of
maybe you're bothering maybe you're
asking too much maybe you're not worthy
maybe you should move on the event that
he talked about me coming to was coming
up
and I still hadn't heard back whether
whether he wanted me there or not or you
know my book launch was coming up too
and I thought
I'm gonna send one more email
uh just one more email that's it I'm
gonna send one more email and hopefully
something happens if not then I'm done
and um hopefully you know he doesn't
think I'm a loser or whatever
and he wrote back an email and like hey
sorry man again I'm not super great on
email I've just been swamped planning
all these things uh yeah come on out
come out to the event speak at the event
too and that was his big event that was
you know 30 to 50 000 a year Mastermind
to be a part of that then I spoke on
stage that then at the event after I
spoke
I met with him and Dean graziosi
backstage for an hour over lunch and
planned my entire book strategy that
then led to me getting invited to go to
Brendan's house uh a couple days later
and hang with him and Dean and Tom bilio
and Lewis Howes and Jay Shetty and
Russell Brunson in all sorts of amazing
humans who built giant businesses all of
that happened
because I sent that one more email
because I followed up and I followed up
and I followed up and I followed up and
it wasn't that he hated me or that he
thought I sucked or that I was being
overwhelming or whatever that that I
kept following up just had the
persistence there's a lot of
opportunities there in front of you
right now
that
just are not happening because there's
not enough follow-up there's not enough
persistence and and I can the reasons
why you're not doing it are based in
reality right I mean I could be
overwhelming it's it's possible it's
possible that he thinks that I'm
overwhelming that I'm not given enough
value that I'm being too selfish that
I'm bothering him I mean it's possible
but we default to just assuming that
instead of actually finding out
and we miss out on a lot of upside and
so here's what I found that really helps
one
you schedule it in
you schedule it in every X number of
weeks right so every two weeks I would
send in another email every two weeks
every two weeks every two weeks every
two weeks every two weeks every two
weeks and I never felt like doing it
because every time I saw that in my task
list
I I didn't want to do it like ah you
know let's give it another let's give it
another few days let's give it another
week you know I never wanted to do it
but because it was in my calendar I did
it
you will never want to do it because
you're afraid right underneath it is
really just fear it's insecurity you'll
never want to do it so you schedule it
in every two weeks or every week or
every month or whatever the thing is
that makes sense to the timeline that
you're on
schedule it in so that you have to do it
so when it came up I knew I had even
though I didn't want to even though my
heart was beaten like
I still went off and I did it second
thing is
lead with the intention before you write
the email before you make the call
before you do the follow-up like what's
the intention is your intention to screw
this person over is your intention to
just suck up their time is your
intention to negotiate a bad deal for
them hopefully not
if you're if you're a subscriber of this
channel uh hopefully it's with its
positivity and hope and belief and and
mutual you know uh benefits and so if
you lead with that intention every time
it's really unlikely that they're going
to
come back in a really negative way
the truth of the matter is they're
probably just really busy
maybe they're doing something
insane in their life maybe they have a
health scare maybe they're in the
hospital maybe their mom's in the
hospital right like you never know
what's going on behind the scenes
and if you leave with intention as
opposed to a copy paste email or just
some kind of spam if you if you leave
with I love this person I want to do
something with them I want to help I I
want to I want to learn if that's the
positive intention going in your your
call your email your follow-up will just
be a lot better it'll be a lot better
and people will feel it I forget who it
was I want to say it was
ah no I forget who it is I'm thinking
princess dive I don't think it was her I
wanna I don't forget who it was where
she would say before I send an email
I would always smile
I would think about the person
and I would smile before I I wrote an
email wrote a letter
and it would always change
the the vibe of the letter right like if
you're thinking love kindness smiling
before you make a video before you do a
DM before you do a uh an email right
like if you're thinking that
chances are you'll make them smile
you know like if you're smiling
before you do it you're probably gonna
make them smile
and so just taking that little pause to
reflect on what is my intention here
instead of defaulting to insecurity and
the stress on your side
default into let's lead with positivity
let's smile let's leave with love
you'd be amazed at how many great things
happen
so those two things
one you put in your calendar
until you get a response like if
somebody if somebody says no
okay
at least you got a response
but again it's likely going to be a
loving no because you followed up so
many times and you've always LED with a
positive intention and love and kindness
they might just say I'm just you know
what I can't do this right now or I'm
not interested or or hey sorry I haven't
gotten back to you let's do this
right A lot of times it's just a timing
a lot of times your timing is way off
and it's not your timing it just doesn't
fit into their life or their world right
now but in two weeks it might or in two
months it might or in two years it might
and if you're following up every two
weeks every two weeks every two weeks
every two weeks and you're leading with
love and kindness and with a positive
intent amazing things will happen
you have a great Mission inside you
you have a desire to serve and the help
and to create great things for the
people who you work with right like that
that is at the core of Who You Are
and that needs to be spread
and at the beginning when people don't
know who you are it's a little harder to
get attention to get on people's radar
but if you are consistently following
through consistently even in the face of
not getting any response you just
consistently because it's on your
calendar you're consistently following
through and you're leading with the
intention of Love kindness positivity
great things will happen
I promise you great things will happen
rule number eight radically change your
life to change your life you have to be
willing to change your actions
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and over again
and expecting a different result
if you want to change your life you want
to be in a different spot you have to be
doing different things now if you love
your life great don't change anything or
you love pieces of your life don't
change anything about those pieces but
if you are not happy with where you are
at you must be able be willing to
otherwise you will stay stuck forever I
was doing an Instagram live yesterday
with a young entrepreneur
he wants to be a speaker and he wants to
share his message and he's constantly
facing self-doubt and fear and
insecurity and nobody's watching the
stories and he's not good enough and who
am I to share a message in in our IG
live one of the things he said was
well I'm not I'm not comfortable doing
that
we're talking about making making
content some days he's on top of the
world and feels great and other days
he's not and he doesn't feel comfortable
getting in front of the camera
and he started going off and telling me
a story stop right there
when you say I'm not comfortable doing
that
we have to identify that as a trigger to
go
saying I'm not comfortable doing that
now if it's against your values I get it
right you're not comfortable you know
I'm at Costco right now Nina's going
shopping in there I'm not comfortable
robbing Costco perfect okay that's
outside my value system that's totally
different most of the things that you're
not comfortable doing
are failing in front of other people
at the end of this what it is you're
afraid of being judged and so we're not
comfortable doing that thing you'll
you'll fail if nobody else sees it if
it's just you but you don't want to fail
in front of other people and that can no
longer be a good enough reason because
if you only do think about this if you
only do what's comfortable
you stay in your comfort zone
if you only do what's comfortable
and therefore you hate your life
because if all you did is wake up and do
what's in your comfort zone do what is
known do what is comfortable do what
do what you've always done you're gonna
hate your life and this becomes the
curse of a lot of entrepreneurs as you
know you're capable of more you know you
want to do more you know you have more
in your heart to go up and serve you you
want that you can you can see it you can
touch it you can taste it you can
visualize it's like I want to be there I
want to do that right has that happened
to you can that relate to you
you know you want more but you're afraid
to go off and do it and and you fall
back down to comfort at least
consistently you might have these
moments of greatness and boldness and
willingness to go do something but we
fall back down to comfort
and if you stay in comfort you will
never accomplish your great goals
because everything you want out of life
is on the other side of your comfort
zone
everything you want out of life
all your big goals your Big Dreams your
big Ambitions your mission the life that
you want the life that you want is on
the other side of your comfort zone and
so I had to stop him when he was talking
to me on the Instagram live because it
doesn't matter if you're not comfortable
doing it
is actually the opposite because you are
uncomfortable doing it now you have to
do it
because you need to train yourself that
you do uncomfortable things the fact
that you have accepted
being uncomfortable as a good enough
reason to stop is the big problem I
don't care what else you're gonna what
other Story You're gonna tell me
afterwards I have to stop the
conversation at that moment because I
could not allow him to continue with the
mindset of I'm uncomfortable so I'm
going to stop
and we all have these words that we tell
ourselves and we all have these stories
that we come back to as to why we're not
able to take action and the problem is
we believe those things and you need to
catch them and you need to root them out
and so for him that was the big aha
moment
that he needs to get uncomfortable and
it sounds
it doesn't sound like a big deal right
like oh of course you got to get
uncomfortable but what is the thing that
you're telling yourself as to why you're
not winning as to why you can't follow
through as to why you can't do the thing
and when somebody else shines a light on
it it's like it seems so obvious
and yet this is the thing that has been
holding you back and keeping you stuck
so I told him anytime you hear yourself
say
this makes me uncomfortable again as
long as it's not against your value
system right this makes me feel
uncomfortable
use it as a trigger to go forward
enlist your family he's newly married
enlist your wife enlist your parents
enlist your siblings anytime somebody
hears you say
that makes me feel uncomfortable that's
that's a trigger go have them have them
hold you accountables that you just said
it again now you got to go do that thing
not against your value system right
for me it's scary difficult and hard
I would accept
scary difficult or hard as good enough
reasons for me not to go off and do the
thing that I want to do
I want to make videos oh that's scary
like oh okay I can't do it
I've just accepted scary as a good
enough reason
and so if I never do things that are
scary I will never accomplish my big
goals
when um
you know when I when I was thinking
about doing my tour in 2019 we had 23
cities 90 days
I thought that was too difficult
too difficult you know like I'm I was
afraid to get on stage and here I am not
facing my fear every four days in a new
city I've never done a tour instead of
just doing a small tour of three cities
or something like 23 cities 90 days you
know a quarter of the year on the road
straight with with my wife and my
cameraman
okay let's go
because I do difficult things because I
want to train myself that I do difficult
things
because again my dream life is on the
other side of me doing difficult things
if I only do what's easy
I'm gonna eventually hate my life
this is where we get stuck
you know when you do something that's
easy
and you win you win a little Ribbon or
an award right you you run a race
against three-year-olds and you win
congratulations amazing you won and you
could post about on Instagram and you
had this little moment of Accolade but
you don't actually feel good about
yourself because you didn't do anything
difficult because that was easy for you
the self-love self-confidence
self-respects comes from doing difficult
things
uncomfortable things scary things hard
things the willingness to show up even
if you don't win
because it's difficult and challenging
that's how you ultimately will win in
life
and start to accomplish your goals and
so
most people are photocopying their lives
this is this is where most people are
stuck you're photocopying your life
today look the same as yesterday look
the day is the day before same as the
day before is why most people do not
like their life is why most people drive
to a job that they hate
they're driving their job to say hey
most people wake up all you know look at
all these cars here most people here in
this parking lot they're picking up
every day and driving to a job that they
hate they do not like their life most of
the people who are telling you what you
should do with your life do not like
their own life and so the answer is to
catch your trigger words so I call them
play bigger triggers
what's a play bigger trigger what are
your trigger words what do you say think
about one of your goals
you know think about what's on your list
of to-do's think about where you want to
be you know what do you have to get done
what's one of your most important goals
right now that you've been
procrastinating on
what have you been delaying on there's
something
everybody's got something
what's the goal of yours that you've
been sitting on and then what's the
voice in your head that that's giving
you an acceptable reason for you not to
do the thing now try to get to the
reason behind the reason
so example somebody wants to make
YouTube videos I want to I want to be a
thought leader I have a message in my
heart I want to get it out to the world
awesome what's the reason why you're
telling yourself you can't do it like oh
well I know the time I don't have the
camera I don't have the gear I don't
have the microphone I don't know what to
say uh all of these those are the
practical reasons right those are not
the real reasons the real reason is
buried underneath the Practical reasons
why do you think that having the right
camera and microphone is going to be the
difference well because you're actually
afraid of judgment you're afraid that
people are going to watch it
we're afraid of one people won't watch
it and what does that mean you know that
you suck and the people will watch it
and laugh at you or criticize you for
having a bad phone bad camera bad
microphone
or they can't hear you or whatever else
like you're afraid of judgment
underneath the reason of
I don't have a good enough camera
microphone Etc
is just fear
and the fear specifically is judgment
so think about your own goals
what do you want to do what have you
been delaying on what have you been
procrastinating on what's the reason
you're telling yourself
The Logical one the one that you're
buying and then what's the reason
underneath the reason
what's the actual reason
and that's your trigger
so if it's fear of judgment if it's fear
failure if it's fear of not being good
enough if the fear of being in posture
if it's fear being uncomfortable
whatever your actual fear is that's your
trigger
and that is holding you back not just in
this one goal but in life in everything
in all your goals it's the reason why
you're not taking action across all your
goals
and so now when you can catch it
and then take the action to say I am the
person who does difficult things I am
the person who gets uncomfortable I am
the person who's going to change my
actions because that's the only way I'm
going to get the life that I want
when you can catch it specifically
it shortcuts the brain
because at least for me and I've seen it
work for many other people when you've
when you've accepted comfort for example
as a reason why you can't take action
and then you hear yourself say well that
makes me uncomfortable
now you have to do it you just have to
do it you take the brain out of the
equation now the reasons don't matter
you said uncomfortable so now I have to
go and do it period rule number nine
figure out what you stand for the
biggest hack to stop caring about other
people's opinions to stop living other
people's version of your life and to
start actually feeling happy and proud
of yourself the biggest hack to doing
that is to figure out what you stand for
to figure out your single most important
core value I believe that everybody has
a single most important core value and
when you figure that out it gives you a
lot more clarity a lot more Direction a
lot more confidence and allows you to
start to to do things that you never
thought were possible all of a sudden
that idea that you've gone up oh my gosh
I could do this thing but then never
take an action on it things start to
happen for you because you have that
Clarity of value so I wrote two books on
this your one word and built to serve
and we go through the process of
figuring out your one word or your who
who are you what do you stand for what
is that single most important core value
one of my favorite activities that I go
through I call it the five essential
questions but the most important one
there I find usually is asking people
who is your favorite teacher growing up
and why
so if you've understood the concept of
hey I need I need to have a core value I
need to know what I stand for I'm tired
of being on on quicksand I'm tired of
living other people's version of my life
okay great how do I figure it out do I
just pick one at random do I just read a
book like how do I actually figure out
what I stand for well
asking yourself that question who your
favorite teacher growing up was and why
I think it's critical think about it
you've had how many teachers in your
life think about your school elementary
school high school uh University if you
went to a college other teachers you've
had
you've had lots of teachers growing up
and
chances are most of your teachers if you
walk past them on a street corner you
wouldn't recognize them That's how
little of an impact they've had on you
think about your high school teachers if
they walk past you right now you
wouldn't know who they were
because they had no impact
but there's always that one teacher that
stood out
there's one teacher that stood out for
you
why it wasn't because they taught you
grade 8 math
is because they made you feel different
as a human
they gave you something more than just a
subject matter they were teaching
and that gives you a clue why did you
like that teacher gives you a clue as to
who you are and what you want to spread
into other people so quick example my
favorite teacher growing up was Madame
Farr Madam far was my grade 12 French
teacher and I didn't love her because
she taught me French I barely use French
and on a day-to-day basis
what she taught me was to believe in
myself
I was a BNC student going into my last
year of
[Music]
High School
and she would meet with me every week
before before school started once a week
we'd sit down we'd chat we'd talk about
life we talk about school we talk about
where I was at we talked about was on my
mind
and in those conversations she made me
feel like I could I could do more
that I that her belief in me created
more belief in myself
and in that last year I went from being
a b and c student to straight 90s
straight A Plus
[Music]
I was still the same guy I still had the
same ability and the same Talent you
know she wasn't passing me the answers
to the test that I had
it was just that belief in me that she
gave me that allowed me to go off and
start to perform more
so I think that's the most important
question you can ask
another one you can look at is what was
your favorite movie growing up and why
so what's your favorite movie of all
time why there's so many movies that
you've watched most of them you don't
remember but there's one that that
sticks out that really stands out for
you in some in some way for some reason
my favorite movie is Seabiscuit it's
about this horse that is way too small
it's about this jockey that's way too
big it's about this owner that's
bankrupt and somehow they all find each
other and start winning a whole bunch of
races when when they they shouldn't be
you know and it's based off of a true
story and it ended up lifting a nation
that people love this Underdog Story and
it's a story of belief same thing
story of belief
we all at least for me I love the idea
of being that Seabiscuit or being the
jockey or being the owner and helping
not just each other believe in
themselves but also the nation
for the audience for the fans helping
them believe in themselves
and so if you started asking those
questions if you started thinking about
who are the people that make you come
alive that make you feel like you're a
better person and what are the resources
or what are the YouTube channels or
Instagram accounts or books or podcasts
or shows what are the things that have
made you come alive what are the things
that have made you feel
like you could do more
and then next to each one write down a
couple of words so your favorite teacher
growing up who was it and then why three
words to explain why your favorite movie
of all time
and then three words why and what you'll
find is as you do this exercise
you'll see some similar patterns you'll
see some words pop off the page you'll
see that same word come up a couple
times
that's your who
that's your single most important core
value
that's what you still need more of in
your life right now and that's what you
want to give to the world
the other great part about it is that
will be with you for life this isn't
something that we want to change this is
who you are this is your best version of
you
at my core I'm I'm the best when I
believe in myself and my biggest problem
is still I need to believe in myself
more to get to the next level
when you figure out your most important
core value you're who you're one word
it's still what you need right now my
biggest challenge right now is that I
don't believe in myself to hit the next
level
and it's what you want to give to the
people around you if you're watching
this you're probably an entrepreneur you
want to you want to give to the world
you want to have a big mission you have
a big message
but some people like Nina who is just
here she doesn't have a big message but
she wants to help the closest people to
her we all want to feel like what we do
matters we all want to feel like we're
having an impact on people whether the
closest people to us or to the world
but we're stuck and we're lost and we
need guidance and if you feel like you
have all these ideas but you don't know
how they all make sense
and you don't know that
you feel like it could be something but
you don't know how to get there
there's not enough momentum happening
is because you're not in touch with your
single most important core value
here's an example if I'm struggling to
do something I'm struggling to get on
stage to speak I'm struggling to turn on
the camera to make a video for you I'm
struggling to launch my next project you
know I get an idea and then I say oh man
I can't do that
what do I need
at the end of the day what I really need
like what's the thing that's going to
turn that idea into actual action
I do more belief
and so when I can catch myself
procrastinating finding excuses saying
no and I shouldn't be I can quickly
reverse it by saying Evan you need to
believe more in yourself
because that's at the core of who I am
and when I can catch it then it gives me
the courage to go off and do it to
record the video to get on stage it
launch that project to say yes to say
yes to say yes I think of uh Alex who
helps me run Toronto dance also his who
was belong
he needs to belong more with himself and
he needs to spread more belong to the
world
and whenever he's not happy and whenever
he's not following through and whenever
he's not hitting his goals and doing the
work it's because he doesn't feel like
he belongs doesn't feel like he belongs
to himself and he doesn't feel like he's
spreading belong to the world if you are
stuck
if you are going too slow
if you have all of this unrealized
potential inside you
thing that is missing
is you not following through on who you
say you want to be you're not matching
that potential
how you make it practical
to figure out your who
because every time you come back to that
and say I just need more of X I need
more hope I need more freedom I need
more belief I need more belong I need
more love I need more care for myself
and then to spread it to the world
and when you can feel that
when you can actually feel that
it'll dramatically change how you show
up
all of a sudden now you're making
progress where you weren't before you're
accomplishing more in a day than you
were in a year
chains you've given yourself wings
you've given yourself the permission to
actually go off and do the scary thing
that's inside you because now you know
who you are
figure out your one word figure out your
who
watch your life change rule number 10
the last one before our very special
bonus clip focus on who you serve focus
on who you are serving instead of who
you're not
that one sentence is at the core of how
I've been able to stay so consistent to
keep making content to not give up to
not get too discouraged and to get back
up every single time and keep going
because I focus on who I am serving
instead of who I'm not
I just recently spoke at Brandon
burchard's influencer Summit and I
shared my graphic of how I've grown over
the years on my channel every time I
show that graph they always ask me how
did you keep going in in the first five
years when you had no subscribers when
you had no comments how did you keep
going
and how did you make so many videos how
did you not burn out how have you made
12 000 videos over 12 years how how do
you keep doing it and I don't think I'm
superhuman I don't think I'm I'm extra
special uh I think I had actually more
problems than most I'm I'm shy I'm
introverted I was afraid of the camera I
felt like only egotistical people put
themselves on camera and told their
story I had lots of limiting beliefs and
struggles in getting my channel and just
belief in myself to put anything out
there I hated my first 350 videos I
couldn't watch anything back totally
embarrassed by everything I made
and it was 750 videos before I inspired
myself before I finally liked one of my
own videos like you know what I'm
starting to get decent at this that was
a good video 750 videos in before I did
that so how how do you keep going how
does that make any sense
because I always focus on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't
most of us just focus on who we're not
serving think about your girl think
about if you've made any kind of content
you know at the beginning you get
nothing right there's no reaction
there's no comments and then maybe you
get one comment and then maybe you get
five comments maybe you get 10 likes or
maybe you get however many views on your
videos right you got 100 views on your
video now that's kind of the standard
now if you get 20 views again on the
video oh that that doesn't feel so good
right or if you get a thousand views on
a video or ten thousand views on if
there are a hundred thousand views on a
video I remember the first time I got a
hundred thousand views on a video it's
like wow I've made it
[Laughter]
and then it's easy to feel like oh the
next video got ten percent of that and
you feel like oh I I suck it's not
working right
instead of focusing on that because
that's a losing game
focus on who you are helping and assume
that it is serving people
I've always felt I think some kind of
responsibility or
just gratitude that anybody would care
about what I had to say and that you
were spending your time with me uh I
remember my first speaking gig was at
the YMCA in Canada was at the YMCA and
three people showed up
you know three people showed up and I I
just did my best to give a great
experience to those three people
and then I kept doing it and and the
next time we had four and then we had
seven then we had 12 and then we had 15
and then we had 20 and then we outgrew
the space and so then I went to the
boardroom of a bank uh Royal Bank of
Canada and took over their Board Room at
night for entrepreneurs the free events
I was putting on just to help
entrepreneurs that no business model or
pitch just serving and then we got too
big for the Royal Bank so then we went
to Indigo which was a bookstore it's
like a Barnes and Nobles of Canada
we had you know people coming out and
then more and more and more every every
two weeks I did it again and more people
came and at the at the height we had the
second most number of people to ever
show up at at the bookstore number one
was Sting when he launched the musician
sting when he launched his book he came
when he did a little concert and that
was the number one event in terms of
number of people that came out and the
second one was my little entrepreneur
speeches
[Laughter]
it's crazy
when you focus on who you are serving
instead of who you're not it does a
couple of things okay
number one it makes you feel so much
better about what you're doing
it makes you feel so much better that
what you're doing matters right we all
want to feel like what we do matters and
if you're used to a thousand views on a
video and then you get 100 views on the
next one you feel like you don't matter
right you feel like you're losing your
value because it didn't reach as many
people don't think like that 100 people
saw it
be thankful and be grateful for the
hundred people it doesn't mean that you
stop caring about growth and Improvement
right somebody asked me about
satisfaction and happiness and they said
I'm I'm always always happy but I'm
almost never satisfied
I always want to be getting better to
grow to improve and it's more personal
thing if I want to put my best effort
out there today this video wanted to be
one of my best videos ever and maybe
accomplish that maybe I don't but it's
the intent because I'm never satisfied
with where I'm at but I'm happy
I'm happy as a human because by putting
out great work and by paying attention
to who you are serving I think that's
the key to being happy to being
fulfilled to feeling like what you do
matters so it gives you that by focus on
who you are serving it gives you that
and number two
when you focus on the people who you are
serving here's a secret they take you to
the people who you're not serving yet
right
if you love this video you might share
it with somebody
you might come back and watch another
video and maybe you share that video
with somebody
when you focus on loving on your
community it's that it's that double
whammy in a positive way of you feel so
good that what you do is having a
meaningful effect and when you love on
your customers when you love on your
audience they're going to take you to
more people because they're going to
feel the love and they're gonna spread
it for you you don't have to tell them
to do it they'll do it on their own
because they get Good Vibes by being
around you even if it's just virtually
I think it's really critical
people really struggling with mental
health
in creation right now in
entrepreneurship right now it's a giant
struggle and I see a lot of my
contemporaries a lot of people on
YouTube giving up after a couple months
saying I need a mental health break I'm
burnt out and I've made 12 000 videos
over 12 years and we're still going
and it's not again that I'm superhuman
it's just a shift
I'm I'm focusing on who I am serving and
who I am helping not all the things that
I suck at and how I'm not growing fast
enough because that game never ends
right it's a never-ending climb
so some years I do better than others
and some months I do better than others
and do I want to have bigger numbers of
course
but it's not the reason why I do what I
do
one other little trick that helps a lot
is
assume that for somebody
at least one person what you're going to
create today is going to be
life-changing
assume that for somebody at least one
person what you will create today will
be life-changing that if you're making
content and 100 people see your video
and you might think that's a failure
because you're used to a thousand views
on your video
that for one of those hundred people
it's a life-changing video
my hope my intention is that this video
today is a life-changing video for
somebody for for some of you watching
for most you watching maybe it's just
another good videos okay thank you good
good shot event espresso in the morning
here we go thank you awesome or you're
having breakfast or you're doing
something else you're driving in your
car on your way to work and you're
you're listening to me awesome amazing
but I hope
that for one person it's it's a
life-changing video it's finally going
to give you the permission to go off and
do the thing that you desperately want
to do that you know is in your heart and
has to come out I I just feel that and
I've seen it enough over the years of
people telling me
that my videos have had an impact on
them
only years later yesterday at
um Brandon burchard's influencer event
that I spoke at
people were commenting and then dming me
on Instagram and sharing stories of I've
been following you since whatever year
and this is the first time they're ever
telling me right they never left a
comment on a video they never message me
they never emailed me they never they
never tweeted they never sent anything
it's the first time I've ever seen their
name ever and they've been a hardcore
follower for a decade
and I've had a huge impact and I'm part
of their daily life and it's only now a
decade later that I'm finding out about
it
right
there are people who are like that for
you too
and we just assume that we don't matter
and we assume because you might get a
few less views on a video or post that
it's not having an impact and not having
a reach and then you take that person
and feel like you suck assume that it's
making an impact on somebody assume that
it's life-changing for somebody that you
are giving hope encouragement motivation
permission for somebody else to go and
become their best selves
when you tie your self-worth to the
results that you're getting
you ultimately are going to lose
because you have some days where you
don't get results
and it's gonna defeat you it's gonna
lead to stress it's gonna lead to
anxiety it's gonna lead to a lot in the
quit it's going to lead the burnout
the key to fulfillment the key to
momentum the key to sustained activity
and the key to actually loving the work
that you're doing
is reminding yourself
to focus on the people that you are
serving
instead are the ones that you aren't
people aren't lazy they just don't have
dreams that Inspire them they default to
thinking I'm a lazy person I don't have
Ambitions I don't know what I want to do
in life I'm just I'm just a loser no you
just don't have a dream that makes you
want to go off and do something and
until you figure that out you're going
to be in this constant cycle of feeling
like a loser it's one of the most common
questions that I get asked on my Ig
streams I go live every single day on
Instagram at least right now while I'm
on my tour and every single day I get
asked some variation of Evan I'm lazy
how do I get out of it Evan I'm
procrastinating how do I get out of it
one you don't call yourself a lazy
person there's no such thing as a lazy
person if you are procrastinating or
you're being lazy right you are being
lazy doesn't mean that you are a lazy
person there's two reasons why you're
doing it there's two reasons why you are
being lazy one
you don't have a dream that's big enough
you don't have something that inspires
you you don't want to get out of bed in
the morning if I was an accountant I
would be a really lazy accountant I
would hate my life not to knock
accountants it's just not for me if I
was a video editor I would be I would be
lazy I would hate my life I don't want
to be a video editor I don't want to be
an accountant actually there's most
things in the world that I don't want to
be and if you've forced me to do that I
would be lazy that's 95 of America I
think 95 of America wakes up and drive
to the job that they hate and then
they're lazy there
but they have dreams they have Ambitions
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
something you just have to find it and
so if you don't know what that thing is
then it's your duty to go off and
explore you test you try you see
you say yes to a lot of stuff like this
is the most important thing that you
need to figure out in your life if you
don't know what your dream is you have
to go off and try things
just like you won't get married until
you go on dates you won't get married to
an idea until you go on dates until you
try it until you say yes
and the asset test is did I like it do I
want to go back this is fill me up did I
enjoy the process of it can I see myself
doing this and having fun because when
you're having fun doing the work
that's when it will fill you up
that's when you won't be lazy and there
has been times in all your lives where
you felt that where you felt the joy the
energy the ambition the drive and so you
need to capture that and say yes and
find what it is that your big dream is
you don't have to be an extrovert to
sell you also
be a slime ball to sell either all you
need to sell is a vision that you
believe in and a passion to make it come
true and if you don't learn to
effectively sell that genius idea that
you have in here that can serve the
world will never come to fruition and
you'll never get the impact that you're
after so I'm here in LA and over the
past two days I've been on the podcast
for Jordan Belfort Wolf of Wall Street
and Jay Abraham who's the legendary
marketing Guru for Tony Robbins and
Damon John and a whole bunch of other
people and I'm on their podcast I'm
telling them that they need to be on
YouTube that they need to get their
message out I want to see them more
heavily invested I want to see their
message reach the world and
five years ago
Evan of five years ago would have been
too afraid to humbled to worry that I
might not be perfect that I wouldn't be
able to persuade them to do the thing
and so I wouldn't have tried
and I still have a bit of that in me
when when Jordan Belfort asked me how
good are you like how good at YouTube
are you and the answer that I gave was
within the thought leadership world if
you you want to help entrepreneurs I'm
I'm top three five in the world
even as I say it it feels weird saying
it because the the Canadian or
Carmichael kind of humbleness is pumping
in but it's also true
because when you're talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get an
understanding when I'm talking to Jordan
Belfort and trying to give him an
understanding of what I do and why my
message is so important for him I'm
trying to serve him I'm trying to help
him I want him to win
so The credibility is important backs it
up and me not strongly believing in
myself means that he won't believe in me
either and one of my favorite messages
from Jordan and I told him this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales
is about a transfer of certainty of all
the things I've learned from Jordan
Belfort that is the number one thing
that still Rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something again not for
nefarious reasons not to screw somebody
over not just to get their money you
want to persuade them I'm here try to
persuade Jordan trying to persuade Jay
trying to persuade lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
YouTube to spread it to the world it's
for them right I got frustrated with
Jordan halfway through the interview and
he said why are you frustrated because
he's making it a joke and some and
having fun and he loves having fun on
the show and and it's a more
entertaining show he's way more funny
and entertaining than I am I told him
you're doing this for the audience
because people watch the show I'm doing
this for you like we're here at a
limited time and I want you to win I
want to get this out of my head into
here so you can go take action on it
right
so the ability to sell and persuade is
based off your ability to transfer
certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing when you fully believe in a thing
like this is right this is a thing that
has to happen in service in service for
your customer in service for your
audience you have to do this not for me
but because it's the best thing for you
when you fully believe it then you have
to go all in on it saying I never have
the time is the single greatest excuse
that is preventing you from
accomplishing your goals you are not
allowed to say it anymore stop it stop
believing your own lies whatever story
you're telling yourself as to why you
can't do it how much time you don't have
somebody else who made it had it way
worse than you did they made it and had
it way worse than you did if they can
make it you can do the only difference
is the story you're telling yourself
that you don't have enough time to do it
so I'm going to give you a more fun
example on this one uh I want to get to
being a better League of Legends player
okay I would play League of Legends
I don't know once or twice a week
depending on what was happening in my
calendar I started sponsoring A League
of Legends player my first Esports
Venture this guy named Kyle menko and he
plays Teemo team was a character in the
game I play Teemo he's the best Teemo in
the world in any region around the world
he is the number one guy and I said Kyle
menko I want to sponsor you and part of
the deal is you're gonna coach me I want
you to coach me on how to get better
I want to get better I want to climb I
was in bronze which is the second worst
division in League of Legends I said
what was the best you've ever done said
silver which is the third worst division
in League of Legends and so he said okay
I can help you how often are you
practicing I said I don't know once or
twice a week it's like okay that's not
enough
I need you to play three games a day
three games a day
and a game takes 35 to 40 minutes
sometimes longer depending on how long
it takes to get into the game could be
45 minutes maybe even up to an hour I'm
thinking my head three games a day are
you nuts I don't have time to do this I
can't make that happen I got all these
other responsibilities
if it's important you got to stop
telling yourself that you can't do it
how do I justify playing three games a
day when I have all these other stuff I
need to do I need to run a business I
want to scale I want to grow my YouTube
channel I want to grow my impact I need
to write my book I need to launch my
YouTube course I need to spend time with
my wife and my family I got lots of
other things I need to do I need to
sleep you have all of it how do I
justify spending three games a day to
improve my Teemo
I don't have the time
your actions map to your Ambitions I'll
look at my calendar I made a way
I'm gonna do it I want to get better I
want to improve
now I don't do it when I'm traveling so
I'm here in LA right now so I haven't
played my three games since I've been
away but when I'm in Toronto
pretty much every day that I'm in
Toronto I'll get my three games in and
I've gotten better the results speak I
went from bronze to Silver and now I'm
climbing up through silver and I'm
hopefully the goal is to get the gold by
the end of the year so that was the
fourth worth fourth worst Division and
you're starting to get
once you get in the goal then you get a
little bit higher now you're starting to
get some kind of not reputation but
significance and just like you're
actually a semi-decent player right so
I'm I'm chasing down my League of
Legends goals because your personal
goals you may be watching and thinking
well what is like why are you wasting
your time doing it's a personal goal to
me
it might be a waste of time to you maybe
building a deck for your backyard is a
big waste of time for me maybe making
your own clothes or whatever other hobby
you have cooking or crafting is a big
waste of time for me right so don't
judge somebody else's personal goals
this is a personal goal of mine I want
to chase it down and I want to not tell
myself that I don't have the time right
as soon as you hear yourself say I don't
have the time you're not taking control
of your calendar you're not taking
control of your life of course you have
the time you choose not to prioritize it
that's that's the change in language you
need to make you're not allowed to say
I don't have the time
instead I choose not to prioritize it
because now you're in charge now you
have nobody to blame because when it's
somebody else's fault when you have the
time that's not your fault
somebody else's fault that's everybody
else who has demands on your time right
you can't do anything about it so let's
just stay here I never accomplish your
goals
choose not to prioritize it
once you take accountability once you
take responsibility to say I'm going to
take control of what I want to do in my
life that's when everything starts to
change you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something but instead of being
world class at that thing you settle for
being just above average at something
that you should not be doing Albert
Einstein once said everybody is a genius
but if you judge a fish by its ability
to climb a tree it will believe its
whole life that it is stupid that's most
people's problems you are a fish and
you're trying to climb a tree instead of
going and being great at swimming this
is the exact problem that I'm on a
mission to solve so I recently had a
young entrepreneur come to one of my
Toronto q a meetups that are free that I
host every week and he said Evan I have
a problem I'm trying to decide between
what my parents want me to be which is
an architect and what I feel uh yearning
towards which is being a musician and I
don't know what to do I know how to
decide I don't know how I'm going to be
a success as a musician I don't know how
it's going to work out and my parents
want me to be an architect and this is
clearly defined path for how to do it
and he's afraid
and I think that's so many people
there's a safe perfect path that has
been designed that people have done
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever or this is new crazy messy
unrealistic unsafe unsure path which is
following your passion being an
entrepreneur and trying to figure out
where you're supposed to go here's the
thing if you only go down that safe path
if you only take that job if you only
listen to your parents or other people
and you do what they want you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you that you could have
done that you didn't take action on and
you hate it
it's never been easier to actually be
yourself and build a business and have
success being uniquely you right this
was not open to your parents and
definitely not your grandparents the
ability to be an entrepreneur on the
side making money using your phone is
something that your grandparents don't
understand it's just it's totally Wild
and so you are a unique individual right
you are I am we all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems you're unique you need to do
something unique if you are unique you
need to do something unique if you're
stuck doing the same thing that somebody
else wants you to do you're never going
to be happy now there may be some
alignment you may not absolutely hate
the job that you're at but you know
you're capable of more you're Michael
Jordan
you are the Michael Jordan of something
you're a genius an absolute bona fide
genius at something this is why I think
it's the world's greatest problem this
is why I do what I do every single day
in making this content videos for you
because I want to unlock people
hopefully more than one at a time but
even if it's just one person who watches
this video and gets unlocked I'm pumped
because I think if everybody is off
doing the thing that they are a genius
at man I want to live in that world hope
without action leads to pain and
suffering watching videos like this is
not enough it might give you hope but
hope that is not tied to action in you
doing something will mean you never
accomplish your goals the answer is
always action
and when that doesn't work out more
action and when that doesn't work out
more more action so a couple years ago I
was in New York and I was meeting with
my agents and one of them
said what am I trying to do what's
what's my vision what's my mission what
I'm trying to accomplish and I said I
wanted to spread belief I wanted to
spread hope and he jumped all over me
about the Hope like you want to spread
hope Hope's not enough you can't just do
hope and and I remember walking away
he's like what's he talking of course I
hope it's so important if you don't have
hope how are you going to believe in
yourself to go chase something down
without hope you got nothing right
without hope and belief you got nothing
where I realized the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people hope things will happen it's not
having hope in something it's hoping
that it's going to happen and then they
sit on their bed and sit on their couch
sit at home and do nothing
that kind of hope that's not a strategy
hope and belief is your first step it's
your first entry point in you have hope
that things will happen but then you
gotta get up and do something right and
so
figuring out that message when I was
talking to my agent didn't come through
right away in the moment because at the
same time as much as I'm filled with
hope and belief in humanity and what we
can all do I'm work right I'm taking
action I'm making three to four videos
every day we haven't had a day in the
past five years where video hasn't gone
up every single day I don't know what
that consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big
I'm working my face off every day in the
achievement of my mission but I also
love hope and belief it's why I have
this channel so I have my other channels
is I want I want to be around people
who've done a lot more I want to learn
from the great so I'm going to learn
from people who know more than me and
when I see that it gives me hope that
it's possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it I can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus actually executing and
doing it are two very different things
right the difference Gap is going to be
the action and so yes I want you to have
hope I think it's important but it's not
the only thing you got to make sure you
turn that hope and not just rely on a
strategy but you're doing the daily work
to chase down your dreams you look at
the people who've made big money they've
been they've been chasing something that
they love doing
because otherwise you won't put it in
enough work if you're just chasing an
opportunity you're probably not going to
make it if you don't love it enough
the people who love it will crush you
like if salsa dancing was the hot trend
for 2020 you could say great I'm going
to make tons of money salsa dancing
being a being an instructor and then
I'll do that for three years and then
retire and go travel the world and do
what I love you'll never make the money
salsa dancing because Alex is going to
destroy you
sorry yeah because he loves it right
because you'll you'll be uh a wannabe
and you'll never put in enough work to
actually get great at the thing like if
you're if you're going to work with
somebody who's going to be in your in
your production
and they're just they just want to make
it as an actor because they think it's a
path to make tons of money because Brad
Pitt makes 40 million a movie or
whatever it is
but they don't actually care about being
a good actor
they're not going to get into your show
like you're going to spot that out and
say no I need people who actually care
about the craft have a routine that
challenges you to be a better human this
is why I make these videos honestly this
espresso series is supposed to be a
morning series that we release five days
a week to help you start your day with a
shot of espresso with with some love
with some encouragement with people who
are doing more than you you may never
meet me you may never meet John astrov
you may never meet Bill Gates or Oprah
Winfrey or Steve Jobs or the people that
I profile on this channel but you can
learn you can learn from them I learn
from them I start my day being around
them and the more that you're around
these people who are living the life
that you want that have the belief
systems that you want you will start to
adopt those as your own as well because
the people around you probably aren't
those people right how many of the
people around you are the people that
you look to and say I want to be like
that person that person's got my life
that person has my ideal values that
person is living the life that I want to
live probably not right and that's okay
you can Inspire them to live a better
life through your actions but you need
to get that push and so the more you can
create that environment around you to
help you get it the greater the chances
of you actually going off and
accomplishing the biggest risk is not
taking a risk at all
I love it so many people are so afraid
to follow their dreams to have this big
idea that they have that they want to go
off and accomplish we have this big
vision for ourselves and we're so afraid
of making the wrong decision that we do
nothing
that you see this big goal and you have
three four five potential paths and you
have limited resources limited time
limited money limited abilities and you
want to say I need to make the perfect
decision because if I make the wrong one
it all falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all that's when you see somebody
else making tons of money off your ideas
that's when you fast forward 10 years
and you still haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that you had
and are crushing it and so the way to
get over it is to recognize that as soon
as you get an idea you need to find some
small way to test it and that you don't
have all the answers and that's okay and
that you're going to figure it out along
the way
don't be
naive like I was to think that you can
create a business plan and it's going to
be the perfect business plan you're
going to have all the answers figured
out and then you're just going to
execute that business plan because as
soon as you finish writing your business
plan and you get out into the world and
you start testing your assumptions
you'll find out that you made a lot of
mistakes that a lot of what you thought
would happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with the perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out and start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
I spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when I
got out to Market I realized a lot of
what I thought was going to happen a lot
of what I thought with the reactions
would be is now it actually happened
and that set me behind
and so being attached to that perfect
idea understand that that doesn't exist
there is no perfect plan there is no
perfect idea as soon as you get
something in your head as soon as you
get an idea for something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it
find some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even enjoy this
a lot of times these big goals that we
have for ourselves when you get into it
you want to be a YouTuber great you
start making videos you're like yeah I
don't really like that go figure that
out as soon as possible people wait
years before they go out and try their
first attempt at it and then they
realize you know what that wasn't for me
and so I strongly encourage you to one
as soon as you get an idea for something
something you want to test out something
that you think might work find some
immediate way to test it on a small
scale don't take a big risk don't go
mortgage your house don't go take out a
giant loan I hate spending money till
I'm making money find some small way to
get started what's the most important
part of my morning routine it's
remembering the intention how do I want
today to go not just having a list of
to-do's but actually writing down how
you want to feel and that message to
yourself they'll give you the extra push
that you need to move it forward come up
with your intentions
whether you want to do my method in the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
a first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what I used to do before writing it down
I just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because I often
forget what am I doing today I don't
know I just woke up I'm tired I look at
my calendar and then with each one I
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it how do I want to show up
for this person if I'm making YouTube
videos how do I want to show up on
camera how do I want to show up for my
audience how do I want to show up for
you I would just mentally think about
that as I go through the day and I
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar that's it and how I want to
feel that the intention going through
each individual item on my calendar what
I love about this
is I find that I'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning I just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully I served I
helped it's often after I answer some
questions on Instagram so I'm in the
service heart and mindset and I think
about how do I want to show up tomorrow
if you find that you have more energy at
night or more clarity or more boldness
at night then then do that think about
how do you want to show up tomorrow what
are your tasks write them down and with
each one just write down what the
intention is how do you want to show up
as a human for each one so not just a
list of to Do's but how you want to feel
going into each one
look is there even as an example every
day at 2 30 I spend time with Nina
okay
every day 2 30. take a break from
whatever I'm doing spend time with Nina
we usually go outside for a walk with
the dogs if it's raining we'll stay
inside and do something together just a
quick break in the middle of the day to
spend time together and that's in my
calendar and on my calendar it says 2 30
half an hour break with Nina
but I wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with Nina I wrote
down have fun and make her feel loved
and I wrote something else down
yesterday but that's my that's my
intention for today have fun I make her
feel loved so last night I wrote that
down I'm looking at Nina she's lying in
bed she's you know about to fall asleep
and I won't think how do I want to show
up for her tomorrow for our break have
fun I make her feel loved
so I look at that again this morning
I look at it again right now
and then here's what's going to happen
at 2 30. 2 30 I'm going to be done
filming my videos I'm gonna look at my
calendar look at my sheet here let's say
2 30 time with Nina have fun make her
feel loved just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
I'm gonna show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something I'm going to
show up slightly different because I
reminded myself that it's not just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved and so if you do
that for all of the items on your
calendar
for every meeting that you've got for
every quiet time that you've got every
creative moment that you've got how do
you want to show up but you can write it
down I love the night before and then
under each one how do you want to show
up that Prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self figure out what your trigger
words are what are your trigger words
what are the things that you say to
yourself that keep you small that keep
you scared that keep you safe that keep
you from living your dreams what are the
trigger words that you use so for me
it's scary difficult and hard whenever I
say scary difficult to hard those are
the things that have become my trigger
words and now I have to go do the things
because I said them because I wrote them
I texted them I sent them I thought them
right when you when you figure out what
your trigger words are then
whenever you say them it's an indication
of here I am again playing small here I
am again telling myself that I can't do
it here I am again accepting these
reasons that I no longer want to accept
being afraid is a classic one for a lot
of people well I didn't do it because I
was afraid and we've accepted you've
accepted the fact that you're afraid as
being a good enough reason for you not
to do the thing that you want to do
and I would like to challenge that and
say that's no longer good enough reason
nope not anymore not for you not for
what you're capable of not for where you
want to go and not for the impact that
you can have nope not a good enough
reason anymore let's go so if you just
sit and think about what are the trigger
words that you say what are the what's
the language that you use that keeps you
small scared protected that you no
longer want to be good enough reasons
that you want to be free of rid of and
that we're taking from our subconscious
mind automatic patterns into our
conscience and to know I am going to
make a change in my life I no longer
want to be this person I need to evolve
and grow and get better and be better
because I'm capable right you so when
you figure out your your trigger words
and and try to cope with them but it's a
good exercise to do right now what are
the words that you tell yourself
when you're scared when you're afraid
when you've got big ideas and you talk
yourself down from them what are the
what's the language you use you can
start by just taking on mind scary
difficult hard or you can come up with
your own but they did become anytime you
see yourself using that language
it triggers you to then make a shift to
say oh okay because I said that because
I said scary difficult or hard now I'm
going to do it just because because I'm
the kind of person who does scary who
does difficult who loves hard
and when you can take those words that
have previously disempowered you and
flip them so that they be they become
empowering for you that's how you start
to shift your identity forward at the
end of the day the thing that matters is
is how you feel about yourself when you
buy yourself the language you use to
talk about yourself the messaging you
have to yourself when you look at
yourself in the mirror when you're going
to sleep when there's nobody else around
you because when you can build that
self-belief when you can build that
self-love when you can build that
self-confidence that self-esteem
that becomes the rocket fuel for you to
build the great life for you your family
the people around you and create the
impact that you know you're capable of
having start to change your environment
so
the more you're around people who are
loving caring
ambitious living the life that you want
doing the things that you want having
the relationships that you want having
the business that you want are not
sitting there stuck and complaining
complaining complaining that's
complaining and blaming together is
complaining people aren't stuck in that
mode
the more they pull you forward the more
the more it forces a more positive self
reflection
so if you're around
Elon Musk and Oprah Winfrey and Marissa
Pierre and Tony Robbins and hopefully
Evan Carmichael you know the more you're
around these people the more you will
start to think like them the more the
way they see the world will start to
influence the way you start to see the
world and it forces that self-reflection
because the easiest way to change your
your viewpoint on something is to change
your environment the fastest way to
learn Japanese is to go to Japan because
you're around it constantly so if you
want to be more loving be around people
who are more loving you want to be
around you want more self-confidence for
yourself
be around people who are more
self-confident what is the light that
you want what are the goals that you
have for yourself where do you want to
be in your health and your relationships
and your business your finances what do
you actually want out of life not what
somebody else's perfect life looks like
right you go on Instagram and you see
people living on the beach and and
rolling around in money like that maybe
that's what you want but maybe it's not
what you want and we get pulled into all
these different directions because we
don't have Clarity over what we actually
want so what do you actually want what
do you want out of life where do you
want your business to be what kind of
company do you want to run what are the
what are the ethics and morals that your
company is based off of who do you want
to serve and how do you want to help
them how do you want to show up in your
relationship who are you looking for in
your partner if you already have a
partner you know how do you want to show
up better for them all of the things
that matter to you to get as clear as
possible so that when you see somebody
else is doing something else and they're
happy great you don't have to go do it
because you're happy chasing down your
goals part of the challenge is we see
other people who are happy
and often it's not even real happiness
it's just you know fake happiness for
the camera but you see somebody who
looks happy you know that you're not
happy and you think well maybe if I did
that then I'll be happy you know maybe
if I go write a poem like they did I'll
be happy and then you start to write a
poem because I hate writing poems right
so it's getting clear over what do you
actually want in your life who's the
person that you want to be
and again from your finances to your
your business to the relationships to
your uh to health the different areas of
your life get as clear as you can on the
things that you want out of your life
you need to make the big decisions in
your life with your heart and the small
ones with your head this is where so
many entrepreneurs fall down this is
where so many entrepreneurs make
mistakes because you see a trend you see
an opportunity you see something that
makes sense it just makes sense on paper
it's so clear that it's gonna happen but
if it doesn't energize you if you don't
love it if it's not in your heart to see
me I can't wait to go off and do that
thing you're never gonna win you're
never gonna win because you're going up
against people who love it you're going
up against people who love it who
breathe it who sleep it who dream about
it and for you it's just an opportunity
you're never gonna win big look at all
your Heroes all your mentors people you
look up to the people who've done it
it's like I want to be like this person
in my field I want to be I want to do it
like she did it like he did it they love
doing the thing they love doing the
thing doing it gives them energy
I look at what I do I'm here in Dallas
I'm about to speak at video marketing
World an annual Summit of some of the
top creators on YouTube to help share
give back help the community give
feedback Train on YouTube I love doing
this stuff what what am I I'm in the
parking lot filming videos for you guys
not because it's a strategy not because
I need to make a video a day because I
love it this this is this is the best
I'm about to go into this meeting to
this conference and I'm gonna hang out
with entrepreneurs all day long from the
time I get in there until whatever time
am I'm gonna be hanging out with
entrepreneurs and helping them with
their business helping them with their
Channel because I love it
and if that sounds exhausting for you
amazing don't do it and if it sounds
energizing for you yes go and do it you
need to make the big decisions with your
heart and then your head's still
important it's like don't lose it's not
the message is not don't listen to Logic
the message is not don't look for
opportunities it's look for
opportunities within the thing that you
love
right if if I love making videos and I
love making content and I love helping
entrepreneurs but I went all in on
MySpace right now I'm gonna lose it's
not the right strategy right you need
both it's working hard plus working
smart it's following what you love doing
plus chasing opportunities but what
takes precedence what's the most
important thing your heart the energy if
you are saying oh man Monday if that's
your mindset around Monday you're doing
the wrong thing you're in the wrong
career you're in the wrong business you
will never be the top player in your
industry it'll never happen for you if
that's your mindset
if you're itching to get back to it if
you can't wait to go to that meeting
can't wait to code can't wait to make
that piece of art can't wait to go and
make that video can't wait to sit down
and write lyrics for your next song if
that's the thing
then you're gonna be successful it's not
going to be easy it's still the long
road it's still a path you still have to
put in the grind and the effort and use
strategies to help you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you you're going to
spend so much time working guys you're
going to spend so much time working as
an entrepreneur
why not do stuff that makes you come
alive why not do stuff that gives you
energy
and so I want you to get out of your
head I want you to stop making decisions
first from your head I want you to stop
making decisions only because it's going
to help you get some goal a short-term
thinking and you're never gonna win
doing it
big decisions with the heart big
decisions that give you energy look at
your calendar are you energized about
the week that's coming up
look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer a little on your phone however
you're loading account look at it look
at your calendar look at the week ahead
are you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do if not you're doing the wrong
stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your Genius your
Michael Jordan level Talent into 10 of
your time you're not gonna get to where
you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made from
the heart all great things every great
business every great song every great
creation
started from here from a place of
passion from place of purpose from place
of energy
and I want to put some pressure on you
guys to go off and Chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail
and they lose a lot of money
it's not
an easy game but one of the biggest
reasons if not the number one reason is
because people picking in the street
people pick a business idea solely
because they're chasing an opportunity
down and they didn't love doing the work
this is why it's so important that you
love what you do it's why it's the
number one rule for Success that comes
up over and over and over and over again
is people love what they do the people
who are winning at the highest level
they love what they do that allows them
to be relentless because you can talk
about being relentless and giving it all
you've got and going all in and grinding
and giving 110 percent
but if you don't love it you're gonna
quit it may not be after a day may not
be after a month may not be after a year
but you're gonna quit when it gets too
hard and you don't love it you will quit
this is why so many entrepreneurs fail
because you're just chasing an
opportunity you're just looking at the
fastest way to make a buck in 2019 in
2020 and 2021 the fastest way to make
some money you're gonna give up
unless you love it now money is
important It's gotta be in your top five
but it's not number one
it can't be number one if money is your
number one you're gonna fail you just
won't put in the work the people who win
have something that they put above money
and that's what allows them to wake up
and be relentless and put in the work
you're looking at a guy here who sucked
at making videos you can go back to my
channel you can watch the First videos I
was nervous I was shy I still am an
introvert but it's through practice
through being relentless I've had my
channel for 10 years I've made five or
six thousand videos across my four more
than four now nine or so channels five
or six thousand videos that's crazy
right that's crazy who does that you
have to love it it doesn't feel like
work making these videos is fun for me
still 10 years later is still fun for me
I'm excited the second that it gets to
be oh I gotta make videos that's it I'm
out because the people who love doing it
will crush me I was looking at my
YouTube thumbnail uh examples I'm doing
a YouTube course right now where I'm
teaching people how to have success on
YouTube how to get your first million
subscribers get where is it get get get
there that gold button get one of those
for you write your thought leader you're
an expert I want you to get a million
subscribers that's that's the course
that I'm launching right now so I'm
looking at my thumbnail experiments
I have a hundred and thirty thumbnail
experiments happen right now on my
channel I'm testing 130 different
variations then I want to complete it
and what what we've completed and gone
through Eleven Hundred something
completed thumbnail experiments just on
thumbnails just testing my thumbnails
we've done over 1100 different
experiments that's crazy
right testing big changes like not
having text on a thumbnail and making it
purple and crazy colors to really little
tiny changes like what if we just tweak
this person's eyes what if we alter the
shade of orange just little tiny changes
that most of you probably never notice
why
I love it
I can't help it
I love I wake up when I think about this
stuff and that's what I want for you
that's what you need to be doing and it
can't be forced Jerry Seinfeld calls it
the torture that you can endure the
torture that you can endure most people
talk about passion and purpose which is
great
but it it's torture for other people I
think everyone is born an optimist and
then your environment sucks the soul out
of most people when you're a baby you
don't stress out about how you look what
you're wearing or how you're smelling
when you're a kid you don't hate your
life and complain about the world if
there's negativity in your head it was
put there by someone and if you want to
change it you need to change your
environment so I've had the good
pleasure of seeing one of my friends
Mark Drager a great friend of the
channel been involved with the channel
for a number of years become more
optimistic become more positive and he
was wondering could I even do it is it
possible he was a guy who was naturally
naturally pessimistic he had a lot of
stuff happen to him like we all have a
lot of situations a lot of circumstances
that made him see the the negative of
what's Happening of be pessimistic of
not being the typical
optimistic everything's gonna work out
great entrepreneur and so what changed
over the past 12 months he's made a
significant investment in himself I've
been hanging around with him a lot more
we've co-hosted a podcast together he's
hanging around me my content garyvee's
content Tom Bill used content more he's
been the Tony Robbins seminar twice in
the past year brought his team with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things are possible
because of the negative upbringing that
he had it takes a lot of unwiring it
takes a lot of shift in your focus it
takes a lot of with purpose with intent
changing your environment changing the
people you hang out with changing where
you the physical environment that you're
in
to make a change I went to Mark's office
and he's moving his office he's created
his own office he's put in a picture on
the wall of himself and then what he
wants to be as as positive inspiration
every day he's looking at what kind of
colors and what kind of furnishings and
and what kind of the core can I have in
my office to make me feel bold to make
me feel alive every single day
it's possible and I think that's the
starting point for a lot of people it's
possible to change your outlook it's
possible to become more optimistic that
negativity that was planted in your head
was put there by somebody else who hates
their life you were not born to wake up
and hate your life you're not born to
wake up and think that it's just
negativity all around the world you're
not born to wake up and be a pessimist
you're not it was put there by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire the years or Decades of training
and in that void you replace it with the
thing that you want if you want more
optimism you you surround yourself with
the most optimistic people you can find
in person on your team in video format
in the books you read and the clubs
you're hanging out with you first limit
access from the negative people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents but you can limit
exposure you can limit access either
with time or just topics that you're
covering and then inject more positivity
optimism to the people books resources
environment that you have around you the
problem isn't that you're not a genius
that you're not talented that you don't
have wisdom and abilities and
resourcefulness and that you're not
Michael Jordan that's not the problem
the problem is you're not focused you're
not doing the things that you need to do
I just came back from video marketing
World in Dallas and I was being asked
about where to spend your time Which
social media sites to spend time on and
I think this is a classic example of
where entrepreneurs fail is you're
trying to do everything and as a result
you suck everywhere and feel burnt out
tapped out and not building momentum if
you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did I get
done if that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and feel like what did I
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
I quoted Andrew Carnegie at my event and
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are one
person show with 18 streams of income
they're making no money
you're making ten dollars a month from
this and 25 a month from that and 18
cents from this you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like I do have got 24
people on my team okay great now might
be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have Michael
Jordan level Talent at something and
that's what you need to find and that's
we need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow there's a reason
why in my videos I say you have Michael
Jordan level talent I believe it it's
true you you have Michael Jordan level
Talent at something you are the best the
absolute best add something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that their world
class has something or two they found
the thing that they could be world class
at but they don't have enough guts to
chase it down they don't believe in
themselves enough to chase them down
here's the thing
you need to First explore you need to
explore you gotta search you gotta say
yes you got to try things you don't know
that that Tim Hortons is your favorite
coffee cup until you've tried it right
you don't know that Sushi is your
favorite food until you've tried it so
she doesn't make sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it Sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish mix it with rice put
seaweed around it and then eat it that
sounds nasty right if you've never tried
it before it sounds nasty but
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you are
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling
the most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how did it make
you feel you might not be great at it I
expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again if you change how you
feel about something you change how you
act the problem is most of the time we
don't catch our feelings if you're
feeling negative angry frustrated
depressed it doesn't matter what the
thing is that you're trying to
accomplish you're not going to give it
your all and you're not going to get
results because of your negative
emotional state if you don't start
changing how you feel you're never going
to make progress on the goals that you
set for yourself so one of the things I
love doing whenever faced in a negative
situation is say it's the best it's the
best I'm wearing this hat says Fanta
because friend of the channel Mark
Drigger pointed out to me when I was
saying it's the best that I'm a reframer
I'm reframing I've never heard of the
concept before reframing means you take
this negative situation and then you
spin it you reframe it so that it's
positive so that it motivates you so
that's exciting so that it pushes you
forward instead of it being a negative
thing that is all encompassing and
depressing and brings you down and he
said well you're always positive because
you're just a reframer and he has his
anagram and I'm a number six or
something I don't know he he can give
you more details you want to know what
number you are and what it means go
follow mark.rig on Instagram and ask him
but
I don't think that's some
everybody can learn how to reframe you
take whatever negative situation that's
in front of you and say this is the best
right now this is the best where this
came from was I was on a airplane from
Vancouver to Los Angeles and that's a
five hour flight give or take and I have
to sit next to this really smelly dude
and there was no other option I had to
stay on the plane I had to make my
flight I had to speak at this event the
only other option was get off the plane
and it was really smelly I'm sure he
didn't want to be smelly I'm sure that
wasn't his you know intention or
ambition it just happened probably had
three stopovers you know I hadn't
showered in in however long and just
he's stuck and in my head I'm trying to
find Solutions there's no Solutions and
so I'm upset I'm complaining you know
the 15 seconds of back and forth this
sucks I can't believe it and then here's
what happens in my head I say this is
the best this negative thing that's in
front of me right now this is the best
this is my chance to show myself what
I'm made of right and so he's sitting
right here next to me I'll look over
and just breathe it in breathe that in
breathe in that smell breathe it in
to show myself
that this is not the limit
that this one dude is not going to ruin
my day and I feel great now about myself
because self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things and I just did
something difficult and that's where
it's the best came from it was a it was
a quick trigger to myself to say this is
the best it's the best and now it's
become this thing that anytime I'm faced
in a really negative situation that
feels overwhelming and possible just
want to complain find somebody to blame
and say it's your fault no this is the
best this is my change to show myself
and the world what I am made of and so
you can flip it for yourself what is so
overwhelming so impossible so crazy that
is bringing you down you look at your
calendar you look at your list of emails
and it's just depressing great this is
the best if you believe like I believe
that your purpose comes from your pain
if you believe that the thing that you
struggled with the most in life becomes
your calling for the rest of your life
the time that you struggled and suffered
the most as a human your your purpose
for the rest of your life is to help
other people who currently are who you
used to be then that thing that happened
that that massively negative thing the
most painful moment in your life
actually is the best because it's going
to allow you to serve hundreds thousands
maybe millions of people through your
purpose so that negative things in front
of you tell yourself it's the best hard
work is your ticket in no matter where
you come from what you look like what
your skills are hard work is always the
ticket in the odds might be against you
awesome now what quit on your dreams or
keep working hard how you answer that
question will change your life so I have
an agent in New York and when I first
started the agency I almost didn't get
in uh I didn't get in because I'm a
weird case for them my agent now he
looked at me back then and this must
have been six or seven years ago by now
and he said Evan I love your message the
problem is you're not a very good
communicator
and that hurt at the beginning because I
had already done some speaking gigs I'd
already been making videos for three or
four years you know I've had hundreds if
not a thousand videos already under my
belt and here he is saying that I suck
at communicating and he said the people
that he typically works with are people
who are already in media who have tons
of experience who are great in front of
the camera they need help refining their
message
he said for you I love your message
you've got a great message you just suck
at being a little communicated like
and so okay great well where do we go
from here and he said I'm gonna take a
flyer on you
I don't normally do this I'm gonna take
a flyer on you and see where you go and
I I didn't want to waste my opportunity
I didn't even know that you could get an
agent as a as a business person as an
entrepreneur as a speaker I mean I guess
I heard a speaking houses but an agent I
thought more entertainment or Sports not
for business so I didn't want to lose
this opportunity you know I didn't want
to regret not giving it my best and so I
said okay great tell me what I need to
do I'm the worst right now awesome I I
don't have the skills that everybody
else here has how can I get better what
do I need to do tell me and he said okay
so your first challenge is I need you to
make a bio video I want I need you to
tell your story a foundation Story video
make it 20 to 40 minutes long and record
it and I'm gonna look at it and I'm
gonna give you my feedback on it okay
great so I recorded it the next day and
it was in the morning and recorded it
sent it to him he gave me feedback
and then at lunch I recorded it again he
gave me feedback I recorded it again in
the evening
and I did it 30 to 40 times there's a
lot over over the course of however many
days you know uh 10 to 12 days I guess
uh I recorded the video over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over again every time you give me
feedback I do it again feedback do it
again
and I got better
and I got better and over the course of
a couple months
when I was making three videos a day
practicing sucking but just practicing
and trying to get better and listening
feedback and trying to improve I quickly
became the best case at the agency I
quickly became the number one person
from from views from subscribers from
Best Practices I copy what Evan's doing
now I'm being brought on to help them
with their clients and train some of
them on how they can get better on
YouTube and build their brand
from being the worst swimming the guy
who almost didn't get in
because the people who are joining them
one maybe had bigger egos but also we're
having a hard time finding the time to
make a video a week
and if they're not making a video a week
or having a hard time doing it and I'm
making three a day even if I suck I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna outpace just
because I'm willing to work just because
I'm putting in the effort you might not
have the skills you might not have the
talent you might not have the looks you
might not have what you think you need
to have
how does an introvert
build a huge audience and and spread a
huge message and be famous on YouTube I
don't know I mean I'm working on it join
me on my journey we'll figure it out
together
that was my agent's concern when I first
got started and I'm I'm breaking the
mold and doing things in a way that
haven't been done and you can do the
same thing
through hard work hard work doesn't
guarantee your success there's a lot of
people who work really hard and never
win a lot of people who work 12-hour
days and are doing minimum wage jobs
they're working hard and they don't win
you have to work hard and you have to
work smart but it's not one or the other
the people who were in The Agency were
working smart but we're making one video
a week
I was working less smart
but making three videos a day so I'm
gonna get better I'm gonna get smarter
I'm gonna make it faster I'm gonna I'm
gonna show you what I can do
hard work is always your ticket in and
one of the biggest problems that people
just aren't working either hard enough
or smart enough
you just want it too soon and you can be
impatient and it's amazing but better
than being impatient with the results is
being impatient with yourself
most people are impatient with the
results like it's not coming fast enough
like where are my subscribers or My
Views it's not happening my first video
took me a year to get three comments and
the first comment was my mom the second
one was my sister and the third was some
random dude right a year to get three
comments and two of the people were my
family
you're impatient with the results what
you should be is impatient with yourself
when you're not getting results when
it's not happening
audit yourself are you putting in the
work are you doing enough work are you
working smart enough are you applying
the right strategies get more frustrated
with yourself and your effort more than
that the results aren't there because if
you woke up every day and did that
equivalent of making three videos a day
when other people are making one video a
week you will eventually win it might be
slower than you'd like but it's always
slower than you'd like but you will
eventually win because hard work is
always your ticket in most people have
not taken control of their schedules you
wake up like an accident start
responding to other people's emergencies
and help other people build their dreams
instead of you building yours it's time
for a change you deserve better and this
video is going to show you how I think
one of the biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs don't take enough action
is because when you get motivated you
don't do enough you feel the motivation
you feel the boldness feel the
confidence but you're not taking enough
action you're not doing enough I
remember going to my first Tony Robbins
event this is before uh I knew Tony
one-on-one before I did the interview
with him on my channel I just went to
see what would the event be like I've
I've seen so many different videos of so
many different people and I felt like
you know what for most people going to
their event it'd probably be the same as
just watching on YouTube but for Tony I
felt you know what I think his event
might be different there's something
that tells me by going to his event
it'll be different than what I just see
on YouTube through the content and so I
went I went with my wife I went with
three people on my team I paid for
everyone to go out and went to our first
Tony Robbins event
and at the end of the last day if you've
never been to Tony Robbins event it's on
fire you're you're motivated you're
jumping you're dancing you're hugging
you're high-fiving you're you're
breaking through limits it's it's
amazing and by the end of the last day
you see everybody in the streets you're
pouring out where everybody's all pumped
up and energized like I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do that
I remember one of the people that I
brought with me he's like yeah yeah I'm
gonna do all this stuff and he's like
yelling and so fired up and excited he's
like what are you doing Evan like I'm
looking at my calendar
because
this is why so many people fall off you
go to an event like that and then you
fall off because you're not making the
consistent success is habits so whenever
you decide to make a change you have to
at least for me I look immediately to my
calendar
so if my goal is now I want to be a big
YouTuber great when am I going to make
videos it's got to be in the calendar
it's not in the calendar it's never
going to happen and so anytime you want
to make a meaningful change you have the
default to thinking what am I going to
put into my calendar because success is
habits and so it's great to be motivated
maybe these videos do it for you maybe
Events maybe books podcasts awesome
you're getting it from somewhere you
feel motivated great show me in your
calendar where you are spending the time
to actually make the thing happen
otherwise you're just living off some
fumes you know you get motivated for a
day or two it feels amazing and then you
fall back down to normal if you want
that dream life you want that next step
for yourself it's gonna come from
changing your habits changing what's in
your calendar to make sure that what you
say you want out of life you're actually
working towards making that happen every
time you say I can't you're teaching
yourself that you suck because you've
quit because you've given up it's not
your fault that you can't do it it's
your work or your school or your family
family or all the other commitments that
you have but not your fault nope
nope
change your I can't to either I'm going
to or I choose not to that's how you
take back control of your decisions and
your life so I recently listened to this
Chinese song and I got obsessed with it
I got obsessed with it I was playing it
all day long and I just I loved I don't
know what they're saying I don't know
which I don't know what the words mean I
just loved I loved it I loved it I go to
bed
and lyrics start coming to me rap lyrics
in full sentences right the first one
comes in okay wake up I'm in bed I'm
lying in bed I'm trying to sleep you
know it's 11 o'clock trying to defensive
idea rap lyric come okay I write it down
again Raptors come write it down more
and more and more write it down until
three in the morning I haven't slept yet
ideas just keep coming for this song
that's like I need to make a rap
and then what comes into my head is that
what you can make a rap
it's easy to get locked in into I can't
mode I can't do this I can't start that
I can't do a rap I didn't go to school
for that not that you go to school for
rap you know I didn't rap growing up I
don't have musical Talent right that's
not what people know me for that's how
people expect from me I can't rap
ah
that's where most people quit
but instead I decided I was gonna get up
at three something in the morning go to
my computer finish writing out my lyrics
and then I spent the day rapping and
that night finished the video sent it
off to uh Christina my Editor to put it
together and the next day we released my
rap video now maybe you love it maybe
you hate it it's gotten some decent
responses it was tons of fun to put
together and most importantly I taught
myself in all of these things these are
all great micro moments to teach
yourself that you're amazing
whenever you say I can't and you do it
that's how you build self-confidence
that's that's the birthplace of
self-confidence self-love self-respect
is taking something that you think that
you can't do and just trying
not even doing it full out because I
don't expect my rap to go off and win
any kind of awards right but I tried it
I did it I released it expect the second
beginning that's okay it's normal it's
part of the process but in those moments
of I can't and then turning them into
something that actually exists
is where your Genius will come
I look at my top 10 series and it's
partly why I have Kanye on my wall
because the first video that I made was
on Kanye first top 10 was on Kanye was
five years into my YouTube career
I did a response to my friend Mark
Draeger
from Phantom media and I said initially
I can't do this like I can't make a
video now on this I have all these other
commitments I have a full day ahead of
other stuff that I'm supposed to do and
said no I did action I'm just gonna do
it forget it I'm gonna make it and I
didn't expect it to do well
luckily it actually did and then that
became this whole thing of making I
don't know how many top tens hundreds
maybe a thousand I don't know how many
top ten how many top times have I done I
have no idea
but it started off as this idea
trust your ideas
know that they're amazing
stop saying I can't to yourself this is
where you need to take control of your
head and your heart you have to make
decisions with your heart and then use
your head to figure out how to do it
anytime you're doing something new super
important anytime you're doing something
new I'm making it I'm gonna make a wrap
I'm gonna make a top 10 video I'm gonna
do anything outside my normal thing
right same for you anytime you're doing
something new it doesn't make sense
because it's new what is brand new
doesn't make sense you're creating
something new and so your head your
logical brain that's designed to keep
you safe doesn't understand it its job
is to to protect you and says don't do
that you can't do that
because one has never been done and
because we have all these reasons why
it's not possible for you not just
anybody else for you you can't do it
because you haven't done it before
that's what your head says your heart
can create something new your heart
creates art your heart makes up a world
that hasn't existed before and so at the
very beginning of many projects you're
having your heart are against each other
your heart's saying I want to make this
your heads you can't make this
and so you end up staying stuck in limbo
with all these ideas never taking
momentum because you're you're ahead and
your heart are fighting you've got your
foot on the gas and the brake at the
same time never moving knowing that
you're capable of more and so you make
the big decisions in your life with your
heart and then you rally your head to
say okay we're doing this I'm making the
rap video I'm making the top ten you're
gonna do your crazy idea and then your
head says ooh okay they're serious let's
figure out how not to die doing this
right let's figure out how to actually
make it work
so you make the big decisions in life
with the heart and then you use your
head to figure out how to go out and
accomplish it if you want to become a
millionaire or influence a million
people you need to learn to build trust
this is where you can really win as an
entrepreneur because people have a
really hard time trusting big companies
to do the right thing so this is where
you win
you win by not trying to be exactly like
the big companies you win by showing
that you actually care and will do the
right thing by the customer so bringing
it to a YouTube world as an example I
think everybody should be responding to
all comments one of the things that I
believe in is every comment we try to
get a response to every comment gets a
response every comment gets a response
and at the beginning when you're doing a
YouTube channel it's easy my first video
on YouTube it took me a year to get
three comments I made a video within one
year there were only three comments on
that video the first comment was my mom
thank you Mom the second comment was my
older sister thank you Alexandra and the
third comment was from some random dude
a new somebody discovered my channel
right one year three comments those are
pretty easy to respond to right it's
super easy in the early days when you're
not getting comrades if you're getting a
comment a day a comment a week couple
comments a day it's easy to respond to
what happens when people scale is they
stop responding to comments because they
don't know how to scale the business
because at the beginning they're doing
everything themselves and it doesn't
take up a lot of time but as you start
getting more comments it starts to take
up more time I get hundreds of comments
every day on my on my YouTube channel I
can't respond to every single comment
personally myself
if I could I could if I did it then I
wouldn't do anything else I'm gonna be
making this video because I was spending
all my time responding to people's
comments right that's the process but
just like any other business when you
start a business you're doing everything
yourself if you start selling flowers on
the street you're doing everything right
you got to find the flowers you got to
sell the flowers you got to distribute
the flowers you're doing everything
as you grow and as you get a flower
store then you bring on a team right and
you have people who are selling flowers
for you and open this door for you
including the store for you you're still
doing work right you're doing more
important work you can't do all of the
tasks in the business at all times if
you're always doing everything you're
never going to scale
and so I believe that bigger YouTube
channels should hire a team to respond
to comments I have an awesome guy my
team named velco so you'll see
responding to a lot of comments and
he'll save the comments that I need to
see so if there's feedback or
suggestions or improvements I want to
see them if this criticism I want to see
it if it's just saying thank you oven
for the video amazing I feel the love I
don't need to see all of those comments
that come in right I'll I'll sort
through some of them respond to some of
them but that's not gonna be the best
use of my time every day because then
I'm not making videos and so make that
equivalent for yourself
at the beginning it's easy to show hard
and easy to show care because you don't
have that many customers because maybe
you only have one customer and so you
can show them the love but as you scale
and grow how can you continue to do that
whether it's you doing that most
important element yourself because
that's the thing that drives it or you
have people on your team that really
show that love and support because you
want to make sure the customer feels
respected and appreciated it's really
easy to build trust in a one-on-one
situation it's harder as you build and
scale your clients and so you need to
build and skill your culture alongside
it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there I'm going to teach you the
entrepreneur success formula this is the
formula it's very simple it's easy to
apply that when you actually execute it
it will change the course of your life
and your business